we're going live we're a little early
because tonight the GOP lesser known
debates is are going to be happening at
the same time Donald Trump will be
having a rally and uh we're going to do
both
we are both uh going to show both uh
we're going to comment on both the GOP
debates and Donald Trump's rally and I
have a feeling we're going to be like oh
that was a good thing Trump said and
then we're going to go back to the GP
debates and be like wow that was a
really stupid thing that they said but
uh it is what it is welcome to politics
everybody we all know that these people
who are in the Lesser known Republican
debate aren't going anywhere near the
White House unless it's going to be in
some kind of cabinet position if that
and that might just be like maybe VI
ramaswami but we'll talk about that and
then uh we're not going to have any big
we're not going to have a members only
show tonight we're going to actually
just do uh super chats after the debate
ends at 10 p.m. but before we get
started my friends go to
timcast.net on the show last night this
is a documentary exploring the
perspective of many people who are
working on guns who uh produce gun
content and it's all about defending our
right to keep in bar AR and explaining
the issues explaining what governments
do explaining why these laws don't work
and explaining why you need to be able
to defend yourself so I think for a lot
of people if you know somebody who's
into gun control show them the
documentary have them watch it ask them
what they think they might be like you
know pull some liberal I don't want to
watch it but uh we've put 100 Grand into
marketing so far and uh we're probably
just going to go go nuts and just dump a
ton of money into into promoting and
pushing this documentary because it's uh
it's about winning the culture War so
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share share the show with your
friends we're going to be making fun of
Republicans tonight joining us tonight
to help us in that endeavor is Robbie
starbu good to see you guys welcome to
the show who are you what are you doing
I am a podcast host I've got a
documentary coming out called the war on
children that'll be out later this year
uh very excited about that and I have
the uh honor of being on the list of the
top misinformation spreaders with you oh
that's right me too me too yep right on
well thanks for hanging out it's gonna
be fun we got Phil hi everybody my name
is Phil leonti I am the lead singer of
the heavy metal band All That Remains
I'm a very failed musician
anti-communist and counterrevolutionary
I do think sooner or later someone who's
like never heard of you and like oh
that's really sad that he there are
people that that that have been tweeting
dude why do you say that you're so
successful BL like and usually I just I
just go ahead and I send him the clip of
Hassan making the little po you're just
tbling you got you got to have you got
to show the clip of Hassan Sayang it
then you got to play the Curb Your
Enthusiasm music with you on stage
before Metallica
I'll see a commenter once more like oh
that's Phil like they they realize who
you are after watching you and they're
like two weeks got me through the
breakup it saved my life it's a lot of
people it you know I mean that song and
and there's a couple others that have
that have really touched some some
people and I'm really really humbled
every time I hear it so I hope to one
day have a story like that that is very
impressive Phil I'm Ian Crossland happy
to be here guys Serge talk to me uh yo
I'm Serge I'm going to adjust your
camera there Phil it's a lot of focus
yeah let's get into it though when have
you're ready unless you don't take
the well I don't know maybe that worked
uh look we're a minute and a half out
from the uh the RNC debate so we we went
live early because usually when the
debate starts right at 8 we're like
quick quick quick we got to rush we got
to rush at starting so uh we're chilling
we got a minute countdown uh how you
doing it's been a good day uh we are
engaging in war in the Middle East again
oh yeah we're bombing Syria was F15
seven uh Nashville uh police officers I
think it was they got suspended is that
what happened which is a horrible
horrible development horrible horrible
being from there very upset about it
these officers should be getting
commendations for trying to tell the
public the truth from where where you
from Nashville from Nashville Middle
Tennessee yeah yeah really so you know
the I would say there has been so much
hubub made about this and so many
different ways by the left trying to
stop the public from finding out the
truth the fact that seven
officers were willing to get involved to
the degree that they must have to be
suspended tells you a lot more about the
left's apparatus to try to shut people
up and not trust the public with the
truth the reality was this was always
going to be better if you rip the
bandaid off you give the manifesto to
the public you let the public have the
discussion because it is going to happen
one way or another you want to drip drip
drip it out it's going to be worse yeah
I made a comment I think a few days ago
about it where I was like let's just
remember it's about the danger of racial
Supremacy it's not about white or black
but like the truth is if you pour a lot
of like white people are bad uh it's and
like the the the only way to combat
racism is with racism mentality you get
more racists and I think this is an
example of that it's really really
disturbing look looks like the debate's
coming on now there we
go I'm so excited for this here comes
the B Team their case on why they're
prepared to be commanderin-chief amid
two Wars on the world stage plan to
tackle stubborn inflation and how they
unite a deeply divided electorate who is
best to take on President Biden and can
any of them first beat Biden cannot be
the nominee so we had that election uh
several elections the other day
Democrats did pretty well people are
freaking out they're like fire Ronald
McDaniel Democrats are freaking out too
they were like this doesn't mean
anything good for Biden in fact it shows
that what Jonathan cha argued is the
Democrats actually could win this but
Biden will tank the Democrats if he's on
the ticket they're going to replace him
100% I've been saying it for 2 years
they'll replace him with Gavin Newsome
he's already running a shadow campaign
right now no question it's why he named
that lady to the senate seat in
California cuz she was the head of
Emily's List which is one of their best
activist arms on the left that secured
the promise that they will support him
becoming the new nominee I guarantee it
he's going to be the
guy they are correct about that Biden is
much weaker than the other Democrats we
have to I'm wondering how they were mov
right right now the the talking heads
are just pattering so we'll just let
them pit patter pit patter D but uh
until we get to the actual uh questions
potatoes who do you think's going to
Winan primary voters bu the people who
didn't watch I think they're going to be
the winners people that are
watching watch us make fun of it are the
winners someone suggested this is Chris
Christie and Tim Scott's last last night
on the stage I think that per it's my
personal opinion but tonight is likely
to kind of be the ushering out of Tim
Scott and Chris Christie if they don't
make some kind of serious move and I
don't see either of them making a
serious move I think that the real show
tonight is us making fun of them yes
100% the the people there are most
concerned with Nikki Haley and with uh
with Ronda Santos Ronda sanos needs to
solidify that he should be in first
place uh or I'm sorry in second place
behind Donald Trump and Nikki Haley is
looking to knock I'll just say I said it
earlier the fact that Will Chamberlain
is not running his campaign is evidence
the man is too stupid to be president
smart guy cuz will was working for him
will is not working for him now and will
put out this long argument calm and
rational without attacking Trump
supporters about why he thought Ron was
the guy and he just gets like look the
disis people are getting vicious will is
keeping it calm and they did not utilize
him they instead put put their morons in
charge let's jump into the debate here
we go Republican primary voters as his
legal challenges Mount Governor Dan
santis let me begin with you on this one
speak to Republican voters who are
supporting Donald Trump why should you
and not him be the Republican nominee to
face Joe Biden a year from now this
country is in trouble and the elites
that have put us here they don't care
about you they don't care that you're
having to Grapple with higher grocery
prices or have higher gas prices they
don't care that your families less
secure because of the open border that's
allowed drugs and even terrorists to
come into this country well I care I am
not going to sit idly by and let this
country continue its downward spiral we
need leadership and we need it now I'll
take the hits I'll take the arrows I'll
take the slings because ultimately it's
not about me it's about you I will fight
for you I will make sure to lead this
country's Revival and I will win for you
and your family actions speak louder
than words we don't have time for
excuses and it's not something that
we're going to be able to have all these
distractions as a veteran I will get the
job done now if you look where we are
now it's a lot different than we were in
2016 and Donald Trump's a lot different
guy than he was in 2016 he owes it to
you to be on this stage and explain why
he should get another chance he should
explain why he didn't have Mexico pay
for the border wall he should explain
why he racked up so much debt he should
explain why he didn't drain the swamp
and he said Republicans were going to
get tired of winning well we saw last
night I'm sick of Republicans losing in
Florida I showed how it's done one year
ago here we want a historic Victory
including a massive landside right here
in Miami Dade County that's how we have
to do it so I promise you this as the
nominee next November I'll get the job
done and as president I will deliver
time is up let me turn to everyone is
spamming high heels and boots and chat
you don't take swings by the
way you and not the former president
well I think you look at the fact that
we're almost $34 trillion in Deb 6% of
Americans are living paycheck to
paycheck 50% of American families can't
afford diapers one in six American
families can't pay their utility bills
you have parents who are worried about
what's being said or taught to their
child in the classroom there's
no we have anti-Semitism all over our
college campuses and students feel
unsafe you've got an open border where
terrorists can come through and we've
got Wars happening all over us and there
dangers around this you know everybody
wants to talk about President Trump well
I can talk about President Trump I can
tell you that I think he was the right
president at the right time I don't
think he's the right president now I
think that he put us 8 trillion dollar
in debt and our kids are never going to
forgive us for that I think the fact
that he used to be right on Ukraine and
and foreign issues now he's getting weak
in the knees and trying trying to be
friendly again I think that we've got to
go back to the fact that we can't live
in the past we can't live in other
headlines we've got to start focusing on
what's going to make America strong and
proud and that's what I'm focused on
doing let's make sure we pay down our
debt I think we need an accountant in
the White House let's make sure that we
have transparency in the classroom as a
mom I know what that means let's make
sure we secure our borders so that our
families are safe let's get crime down
because our families want to know that
they can be safe no matter where they go
and as the wife of a combat veteran I
will tell you a military needs to know
we have our back and we need to make
sure that America is how does she talk
like that with her teeth not opening her
R she's talking like this you know what
I
mean the majority of the the Republicans
up here when it comes to domestic policy
I don't think that they're going to have
anything that I would be strongly
against but but uh her foreign policy is
completely and totally out of the
question oh out let me turn to you
please make your case why would you
uh why should you be the nominee and not
the former president I think there's
something deeper going on in the
Republican party here and I am upset
about what happened last night we part
losers at the end of the day was it
cancer in the Republican establishment
let speak the truth I mean since Ronald
McDaniel took over call call out 2018
2020 2020 no red wave that never came we
got trounced last night in 2023 and I
think that we have to have
accountability in our party for that
matter R if you want to come on stage
tonight you want to look the GOP voters
in the eye and tell them you resign I
will turn over my yield my time to
you the people cheering for losing in
the Republican Party think about who's
moderating this debate
this Jo and Elon Musk we'd have 10 times
the viewership asking
questions voters actually care about and
bringing more people into our party
totally you think the Democrats and we'
got Christian weler here you think rats
would actually hire Greg Gutfeld to a
democratic
debate use this time CU this actually
about you in the media and the corrupt
media establishment see the Trump Russia
collusion hoax that you pushed on this
network for years wow was that real or
was that Hillary Clinton made up
disinformation answer the
question for
you whoa did he just knock did he just
knock uh
the 201 election they rigged the 2020
election with the hunter Biden laptop
story and they're going to rig this
election accountability
let honestly maybe the best line out of
all the debates that there's been
was best open debate I think I've seen
my whole life Christie why you and not
former president
Trump look you said it at the beginning
of the debate we are dealing with
extraordinarily
important issues facing this country
right now wait are those on Ally in the
Middle East fire from a terrorist group
that
has to wiping them and every Jewish
person in this world off the map we have
Ukraine with Vladimir Putin a communist
KGB dictator who wants to put the old
band back together he's starting in
Ukraine and he's going to move to the
baltics and Poland after that he's not
you no in this country that is choking
choking every American family that wants
to try to rise up and give their
children a better life and tonight we
need to decide which president's going
to be the one to tackle the big issues
who's going to make this country look
once again not just inward but look
outward at the world and say America is
the country the indispensable nation
that makes this a safer world and in a
safer World American innovation American
hard work has always been the thing that
has driven our country to greater things
I'm going to be the president who will
do those big things we're not going to
be small and I'll say this about Donald
Trump and a half of their life focusing
on keeping themselves out of jail and
courtrooms cannot leave this party or
this country it needs to be said plainly
Governor thank you let me turn to
Senator Scott Senator Scott you've said
former president Trump can't win make
your case to Republican voters well
certainly none of what I would say
without any question is that the truth
of my life destroys the lies of the
radical left we need a president and a
candidate who will actually help our
base solidify and attract independent
voters into our party the great
opportunity party is now winning back
African-American voters and Hispanic
voters because we are working on a
foundation based on faith our nation is
facing some deep challenges it is a loss
of faith in this nation that is part of
the erosion that we're seeing every
single day it's restoring Faith
restoring our Christian values that will
help this nation once again become the
city on the hill when Ronald Reagan
talked about the city on the hill he was
coming from Matthew 5 when President
Lincoln talked about A House Divided
that was Mark our founding documents
speak to the importance of a faith
Foundation you don't have to be a
Christian for America to work for you
but America does not work without a
faith-filled judeo Christian Foundation
I would be the president that helps us
restore faith in God faith in each other
and faith in our future without that
Focus none of the issues the policies
matter we have to get back to being a
nation that isn't in fact the city on
the hill that believes in each other
enough for us to fight for
that I just want to say real quick the
didn't answer the question about why he
should be the president over Trump oh
yeah just showed us why it's an
impossible question to answer you don't
want to piss off the Trump base but he
knows how to answer the question a in a
political way oh yeah
100% Ian's right he just demonstrated he
demonstrated the kind of leadership the
kind of aggression
kind of confidence that you want in
someone that would be and didn't anger
Trump if
heah to do at this moment Governor desis
I would be telling BB finish the job
once and for all with these butchers
they're
terrorists they're massacring innocent
people they would wipe every Jew off the
globe they could he cannot live with
that threat right by his country that
Hamas should release every hostage and
they should unconditionally surrender
I'm sick of hearing the media I'm sick
of hearing other people blame Israel
just for defending itself we will stand
with Israel in word and in deed in
public and in private and I can tell you
as Governor I actually did something
about it Biden's neglect has been
atrocious uh we had Floridians that were
over there after the attack he left them
stranded they couldn't get flights out
so I scrambled resources in Florida I
sent planes over to Israel and I brought
back over 700 people to safety there
could have been more hostages had we not
the lack of specificity in the opening
is the problem because of
US Iraq and
Afghanistan could feel like hey let's we
want to break this open to a huge Wide
War instead of targeting Hamas so
there's a difference between words and
deeds we acted and we saved lives thank
you Ambassador Haley what would you do
what would you be urging prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu to do would you
consider humanitarian pause for example
the first thing I said to him when it
happened was I said finish them finish
them and the reason is I worked on this
every day when I was at the United
Nations and we have to remember that
they have to one eliminate Hamas two
support Israel with whatever they need
whenever they need it and three make
sure we bring our hostages home we need
to be very cleare eyed to know there
would be no Hamas without Iran there
would be no Hezbollah without Iran there
would not be the houthis without Iran
and there wouldn't be the Iranian
militias in Syria and Iraq that are
trying to hear hit our military men and
women if it hadn't been for Iran and who
is funding Iran right now China is
buying oil from Iran Russia is getting
drones and missiles from Iran and there
is an Unholy Alliance we need to be
clear i' the last thing we need to do is
to tell Israel what to do the only thing
we should be doing is supporting them
and eliminating Hamas it is not that
Israel needs America America needs
Israel they are the tip of the spear
when it comes to this Islamic terrorism
and we need to make sure that we have
their backs in that process do mean of
The Spar in regards to this Islamic
terrorism it's causing it I think she
means the ti of The Spar in the war
against Iran personally I think she
means like they're going to be the first
sacrif I would go one step further the
founding vision of Israel was based on
the idea that don't want to depend on
anybody else's sympathy or Direction in
defending themselves so what I would
tell BB is that Israel has the right and
the responsibility to defend itself I
would tell him to smoke those terrorists
on his Southern border and then I'll
tell him it's president of the United
States I'll be smoking the terrorists on
our Southern border that's his
responsibility this is our
responsibility that's how we move
forward but I want to be careful to
avoid making the mistakes from the
neocon establishment of the past corrupt
Millions themselveses like Iraq and
Afghanistan Wars thousand of our sons
and daughters my age to die in that did
not Advance anyone's interests adding 7
trillion to our national debt and Joe
Biden sold off our foreign policy Joe
Biden's son Hunter Biden got a $5
million bribe from Ukraine that's why
we're sending $200 billion back to that
same country the fact of the matter is
the Republican party is not that much
better you have the likes of Nikki Haley
who stepped down from her time at the UN
bankrupt or in debt is was her family
then she becomes a military contractor
she joins the board of Boeing and
otherwise and is now a multi-millionaire
so I think that that's wrong when rep do
Democrats do it that's the choice we
face do you want a leader from a
different generation who's going to put
this country first or do you want Dick
Cheney and three
Shields oh
no
you're the president you're on the phone
in the Oval Office with the Prime
Minister he's been working on
these we need the Joe Rogan meme from
the UFC
fire responsibility right to wipe Hamas
off of the
map we will support you we will be there
with you we'll stand shoulder Tosh
shoulder there will be no daylight but I
would change the the station a little
bit though and head back home to to
America I would say to President Biden
diplomacy only is a weak strategy
appeasement leads to war from President
Obama to President Biden Obama sent
Millions to Iran frankly President Biden
has sent billions to Iran that is why
I've said that there's blood dripping
from the hands of President Obama and
President Biden I would tell President
Biden with great clarity if you want to
stop the 40 plus attacks on milit milary
Personnel in the Middle East you have to
strike in Iran if you want to make a
difference you cannot just continue
strikes in Syria on warehouses you
actually have to cut off the head of the
snake and the head of the snake is Iran
and not simply their proxs in order for
us to have a powerful response now every
time from America we're not sending our
young to strength un States my forign
policy is
notate
evil Advanced arator Scott thank you I
want to get you way here look Lester
these problems are so big and serious
that the first thing I would say why he
keep making size references I'm trying
to be responsible here matter what it is
you need at any time to preserve the
state of Israel remember that hamas's
main goal is to get rid of Israel is to
get Israel absolutely off the map now
there are three things I think I would
say to him when he asked for advice the
first I would say is that it is
absolutely your obligation to all right
real quick I got to read the Super Chat
from Daniel TR uh trunks TR he says I'm
confused Dick Cheney and 3in heels is he
talking about Nikki Haley or Ronda
s it creates greater unrest in the
entire region second you must go in and
make sure that Hamas can never do this
again
the fact is that Israel and their
intelligence Community failed they
failed here and they failed the people
of the state of Israel and so we need to
work closely and better together to make
sure one that they're degraded and two
that we know everything that's going on
inside Gaza Strip when it's going on so
that something like this can't happen to
kill, 1400 individuals again and the
third thing is to keep your eye on the
ball make sure that we continue to
isolate Iran work with the reasonable
Nation nations in the Middle East the
other Arab Nations who want to partner
with you and make sure that we continue
to isolate Iran so their only friends in
the world are the part of the evil
forsome China Russia Iran and North Kore
Christie thank you very much we're going
to continue in this vein right now with
a question from Matthew Brooks the CEO
of the Republican Jewish Coalition a
partner of the Republican National
Committee in this debate here it
is given attacks by Iranian back proxy
groups on us military bases in Syria and
Iraq attacks that have wounded
approximately two dozen of our US
servicemen do you support the use of
military force by the United States
against Iran no Governor haly would you
please answer that yes I'd first like to
say they're 5 in heels and I don't wear
them unless you can run in them so she's
accepting she's Dick Cheney we got two
of you on stage he said you hear what he
said we got two of you on stage he are
not our F statement there for ammunition
what we need to be doing
for is first of all the idea that our
men and women could be targeted and that
we've allowed almost aund hits to happen
under Biden's watch is Unthinkable we
need to understand this is Iran giving
the green light telling them what to do
and we shouldn't be doing the tip fortat
like what Joe Biden has done we need to
go and take out their infrastructure
that they are using to make those
strikes with so they can never do it
again Iran responds to you punch them
one and you punch them hard and they
will back off what we don't need is
Biden falling all over himself to get
back in the Iran deal him giving $6
billion do to get five hostages home him
telling Netanyahu now that he needs a
pause or a ceasefire we don't need him
going and sitting there tiptoeing around
Iran because he thinks they're going to
do something you don't respond to an
enemy and a terrorist with fear you
respond with strength when you do that
that's when the world pays attention and
that's when Iran stops thank you
Governor danis if I can continue with
you just today the US launched another
one of its limited air strikes against
Targets in Syria this time Iranian
linked facility how far would you go
militarily to hold Iran accountable well
first Matt thanks for your question and
I appreciate what you've done over the
last month I know it's been very
difficult for the community and
appreciate you guys rallying together in
difficult times uh I actually served in
Iraq back in the day and um we had
al-Qaeda in Iraq you had Shia militias
that were funded by Iran that were
killing hundreds and hundreds of US
troops and as commanderin-chief I am not
going to put our troops in harms way
unless you're willing to defend them
with everything you have Biden has them
out there they're sitting ducks he's
doing glancing blows that's just
inviting more attacks from the Iranians
I would would say you you harm a hair on
the head of an American Service member
and you are going to have hell to pay we
are not just going to sit there and let
our service members be sitting ducks and
that's true whether it's the ran or
whether it's any country on the world we
have to be strong and we have to defend
the people who defend us all right thank
you Governor now our second and final
question for Matthew Brooks of the
Republican Jewish Coalition please
watch Jewish students across the country
are threatened and under attack yes they
are what do you say to Jewish students
on college campuses who feel unsafe
given the dramatic rise in anti-Semitism
and what do you to say to University
presidents and college presidents who
have not met the moral Clarity moment to
forcefully condemn Hamas terrorism it
was a professor who killed that Jewish
elderly man absolutely I think the
scourge of anti-Semitism across this
country including at places like my alma
mats in places like Brooklyn Bridge and
New York it's sad to see but here's what
history teaches us anti-Semitism is a
symptom of a deeper cancer in a country
in a society that is lost and we are
lost several years ago when I wrote my
first book woke Inc I was talking about
they were chanting death to America
death to white people death to
Christians nobody was waking up back
then now it's even bad now they're
saying death to Israel and worse so it
is wrong but we have to get to the root
cause here now I think it's really
important that we do this through
leadership not censorship leadership
means fill that void with purpose and
meaning dilute this wokeism and
anti-Semitism to irrelevance these kids
they have no idea what the heck they're
even talking about when they're siding
with Hamas over Israel they are fools
but I also want to caution here if we go
the direction of Rona santis or Nikki
Haley with whom I respectfully disagree
on this issue Pro censorship telling
student groups to disband mark my words
soon they will say if you question a
vaccine and it side effects you're a
biot terrorist soon they will say that
if you show up at a school board meeting
you're a domestic terrorist soon if they
say that j6 prisoners should be released
you're an insurrectionist terrorist so
that's where this road ends we don't
quash this with censorship because that
creates a worse underbelly we quell it
through leadership by calling it out
these University administrators have
lost their way and we need leadership at
the top in the United States of America
that restores our founding values and
that has no place for this kind of anti
Semitic hate that's where I stand while
he when r s made that move I talked to
him about it and he was critical of what
Ron did in shutting down these groups
despite the fact they claim to be Hamas
but I said I said that to I was like hey
man these these they're claiming to be
Hamas to support Hamas and then he said
effectively he was saying he was like no
way dude if you let him make this move
it's just a bunch of dumb kids they're
going to go after everybody to our
country on a visa to a college campus
your Visa is a privilege not a right
number
three any campus that allows for
anti-Semitism and hate to allow students
to encourage terrorism mass murder mass
murder and genocide you should lose your
federal funding to day period to all the
students they all visas they all should
every single they should lose their
Federal funding anyway
schol like
all complaining about
really gone after d hard the students
are they freaking out Dave Ruben called
them names
and support Jewish citizen has the right
to walk on the streets of America with
no fear they have the right to go to
college campuses go to class and not
fear we will restore that I started
working on anti-Semitism on college
campuses in 20
2017 because even then there was a rise
of anti-Semitism on college campuses we
must Force the people off those campuses
and thank you let me let me turn to the
governor s here what do you think about
little FAS buddy y I was the first
presidential C to say if you are here on
a suan Visa as a foreign National you're
making common cause with Hamas I'm
cancelling your visa and I'm sending you
home no questions asked
second I have friends here in Florida
who their kids do not feel safe even
going to University campus at all
outside of the State of Florida you have
Jewish students fleeing for their lives
at Cooper Union Joe Biden should have
the Department of Justice on these
college campuses and holding the
universities accountable for civil
rights violations when you have you
should not have money going to these
places I already acted in Florida we had
a group students for just of Palestine
they said they are common cause with
Hamas they said we're not just in
solidarity this is what we are we
deactivated them we're not going to use
T tax do to fund Jihad no way and what
is
Biden helping the Jewish students being
that should be the line if you're if
you're actually a party to supporting a
terrorist group then charge them an they
shut them down and told them to reform
that is what we that's a good point
because because that speaks to more
issues just like the freedom of speech
and like when you're talking about like
if someone is is too dangerous to get on
AE there shouldn't be no fly list there
should be
charges yeah do something all this this
this half measure and maybe they might
be dangerous so we're going to violate
their civil rights no can all be used to
violate our civil rights that's really
what it's about they make the proud a
terrorist
organization but I do agree with having
the doj investigate civil rights
violations because these farf are
targeting actual Jews with violence not
Israelis they're coming to universities
so that I agree with but desanding a a
group no no no if they go out and
threaten people okay if he said they
were threatening Jewish students on
campus I'd say okay he's right yeah
charges charges not these secret lists
not these red flag laws if if someone's
dangerous charge them have a exactly we
have a justice system for a reason and
we have amendments that are that are
alleged or ostensibly supposed to
prevent the federal government from
doing things like putting people on
list I do like pulling the student visas
though if you're not an American citizen
I don't think you're entitled to the
same you know sort of uh you know us
being careful with your rights okay if
you're not from here and you're showing
us even the possibility that you're
going to align with Terror like you're
good to go we're going to we're going to
ask you to leave I do love he said
Tucker Elon and Rogan hosting the debate
10 times the viewership
bro it would be like
300 going on either against Jewish
Americans in New Jersey or Muslim
Americans in New Jersey it takes
leadership Lester to know how to do this
you must work with both sides both sides
need to know it but let us never have a
false moral equivalence between Hamas
and Hezbollah and the Jewish people the
Jewish people stand for right and
Justice and Hamas and Hezbollah stand
for death Chrissy thank you Ambassador
Haley what do you say to Americans who
are simply afraid right now in this in
this current environment that we're
talking about I think it you know you
look at the the country and the country
is all out of sorts I think look at what
these kids are dealing with on college
campuses what makes me so angry is not
only do you have the kids barricaded
Library said they were going to shoot up
the coer dining hall you've got kids
dorm rooms who are being set on fire
because they have something related to
Israel on their doors no person should
ever feel in danger like this and this
is what I would say about our College
presidents is if the KKK were doing this
every College president would be up in
Arms This is no different you should
treat it exactly the same anti-Semitism
is just as awful as racism and we've got
to make sure they're protected and for
everybody that's protesting on these
college campuses in favor of Hamas let
me remind you something Hamas said death
to Israel and death to America they hate
and would kill you too and the idea that
they're talking about genocide for the
Jewish people that's not the values of
America that's not us we're better than
that we
don't we don't need to celebrate
genocide we don't need to celebrate
violence towards anybody we need to go
back and soul search in our country and
remember what we are about and we are
about taking care of people not going
and making them live in fear because
some other terrorist activity says they
want to destroy them Ambassador thank
you Kristen ler thank you this is
another I didn't really understand that
just a lot of mumo J she conflating
Jewish with Israel which is a big
problem United States has given Ukraine
the one part I agreed with was that you
know these people would want to kill us
too obviously you know told me on Sunday
if Russia is St now quote the price will
be higher for the United States and
Americans would be forced to quote send
your sons and daughters to defend NATO
countries Senator Scott where do you
stand on more funding for Ukraine I
certainly have been very supportive of
Ukraine I believe that ultimately we
should make sure that the president of
United States states what is America's
national vital interest in Ukraine it is
actually integrating the Russian
military we've been very effective using
our resources and our weaponry and the
incredibly high price
of Ukrainian blood to achieve that
objective every day we get closer to the
degreg of the Russian military and
that's good news but the American people
are frustrated that they do not have a
president who reminds us and tells us
where's the accountability where are
those dollars how are those dollars
being spent we need those answers for us
to continue to see the support for
Ukraine and at the same time I would say
that a
package see what Trump do
I oppose the use of young Ukrainian
bodies and their blood yeah we can so
that we can irritate Russia I don't
think we the Trump rally doesn't want
play the Russians are advancing their
military through this conflict they're
learning new tactics figuring out what
weapons don't work shutting down free
speech taking bribes and kickbacks to
enrich themselves and their very spoiled
children about to go to R SW oh he's
with the Cubans Ina rigging and Che he
said they're going to after this guy I
have a feeling they're going to V cover
up their
colossal all of talk we're not getting
the connection for Trump so you know
what our war strategy in America should
be like we should have an operating
procedure for all elected officials that
when we take a vote which we should vote
to go to war or not when that happens
politicians should have to either
themselves agree to go to the front
lines or one of their children or
grandchildren if you did that we' be a
much more peaceful people to understand
where the resources have gone number one
number two after we have that that
responsibility taking care of an
accountability then we have an
opportunity to look at the overall
strategy that helps us to grade the
Russian military while we use our
resources to degrade the Russian
military the Russian military is not on
with the United States
military with absolutely essential as
you understand Article 5 would require
to support and to defend NATO our troops
on the ground the fastest way for us to
eliminate that possibility is for us to
destroy to an extent possible the
Russian military by doing so we actually
achieved the objective of keeping our
military home and that's good new thank
you Senator Scott Mr Ramen Swami are you
persuaded by President zelinsky's urgent
new plea where do you stand on more fun
I'm absolutely unpersuaded yes I'm
actually enjoying watching the Ukraine
Hawks quietly delicately tiptoe back
from their position as the has Unwound
into disaster first of this race I was
the only person standing for it now
they're actually quietly coming around
to being more cautious as they should
level with the American people here
Ukraine is not a paragon of democracy
this is a country that has banned 11
opposition parties it is Consolidated
all media into one state TV media arm
that's not Democratic it has threatened
not to hold elections this year unless
the US Forks Over more money that is not
Democratic it has celebrated a Nazi in
its ranks the comedian in cargo pant
called zalinsky doing it in their own
ranks that is not Democratic more facts
for you that you won't hear from the
mainstream in either party or the
mainstream media the regions of Ukraine
that are occupied by Russia right now in
the donbas Lans donet these are
russian-speaking regions that have not
even been part of Ukraine since 2014
that other people probably couldn't name
those provinces for you majority do want
ran fact and so to frame this as some
kind of battle between good versus evil
don't buy it and like the likes of the
the sharpest of the warhawks on Ukraine
Nikki Haley to have some accountability
and answer do you want to use US
taxpayer money to fund the Banning of
Christians that is actually what's
happening they're using the Ukrainian
Orthodox Church they have banned them
the Ukrainian Parliament just did this
last week supported by our dollars and I
think you owe it to the American people
Nikki to at least this
one
Christians s Mr ramaswami thank you we
ask the questions Ambassador H what is
your take on more fund let hear the
response Let's see we ask the question
I'm telling you Putin and president she
are salivating at the thought that
someone like that could become president
they would love to
see this is what I will tell
youing not the 9s anymore you had your
time to talk the Ambassador has the
floor Ambassador the first thing I'll
tell you is we all remember what that th
did when he invaded Ukraine we all know
that half a million people have died
because of Putin and here is a freedom
loving pro-american country that is
fighting for its survival and its
democracy no I don't think we should
give them cash I think we should give
them the equipment the ammunition to win
and I'll tell you if Biden had done it
when they first asked for it this war
would be over but let's also remember
this massive cap that is so when you
left Afghanistan in shambles and left
them with a ton of weapons and money
it's not that we left it's how we left
when you look at Ukraine don't think for
a second now everybody wants to move
away from Ukraine they'll want to move
away from Israel a year from now America
we wanted to move no we wanted to move
away from Ukraine right away immediately
we wanted to not ever move in now is the
time to get
partnership alliance between Russia
Ukraine and China is real there is a
reason the Taiwanese want us to support
the ukrainians it's because know that
China is coming after them next there is
a reason ukrainians want us to support
Israelis because they know that if Iran
wins Russia wins we have to see the
combination ofad can't keep funding Wars
all over the world that's her
argument this other country is going to
want our money and this other one and if
we don't give our money to this one then
the next one's going to be worried they
won't get our money it's like none of
them should be getting our money it's
boilerplate a couple she was like I
don't want to give him money I want to
give him arms
like how you going to pay for that Stu
money this is the price we pay for being
the Le is trying to do this like solemn
Som he uses Lester's name over and over
again he did the Donald Duck and that
flopped so now he's trying to do the I'm
must be
serious shude and they are all working
to support Russia right now my ADV to
Chris reason they're doing is because
dictators work together people who
believe in democracy work
one all those that are standing up for
democracy and freedom in this world and
by the way let's of this 1992 this
country made a promise to Ukraine we
said if you return nuclear missiles that
were part of the old Soviet Union to
Russia and they invade you we will
protect you he is correct an American
promise that's 31 years old is no
different than American promise that's
made tonight on this stage we need to
stand by it and those of us who forget
history are doomed to repeat it and the
that's right I'm trying to remember the
history of Iraq and Afghanistan absolute
giving in to dictators which is being
suggested on this stage just shows the
immaturity of the approach peace is not
giving into dictators I love how they
think peace and wanting peace is
immature and they're like why don't you
want to bomb more people and kill more
18y olds that's mature any suggestion by
zalinsky or anyone else that we should
they we're going to eventually have you
troops there I can tell the American
people when I'm president that will not
happen we are not going to send your
sons and daughters to Ukraine I am going
to send troops to our Southern border if
you look at the threats that we Face
terrorists have come in through our
Southern border I'm going to shut it
down I'm going to have the military and
I'm going to deport the people who've
come particularly under Biden who've
come from the Middle East come from all
these places now Biden wants $105
billion UH 60 most of that's Ukraine
including some of it going to pay
pensions for bureaucrats and salaries
that is a total ridiculous use of
American tax dollars he says he has
money for border to try to do the media
repeat that when you look at it what
most of the money is is money to process
more illegal aliens into this country
how is that solving the problem that's
making the problem worse and what does
he do for the Indo Pacific a pittance
that is the top threat that we Face we
need to bring this war to an end we need
the Europeans to step up and do their
fair share and we need to get serious
about the top threat that this country
faces which is the Chinese Communist
party so if I may respond to the Ukraine
question in fact we are going to go from
the hot Wars in only War skep people are
call apparently yeah I mean Ron is doing
a dance you know he's dancing
between I hate that more than anything
many repic
believe General Secretary X is an
existential threat to the United States
the flash point is Taiwan for decades
and decades the American Military but
primarily the United States Navy has
deterred an attack from China to the
Island state of Taiwan but Ronald
Reagan's Navy of 600 chips is gone now
the question to you is and I'll start
with you Ambassador Haley because you
were in president Trump's cabinet his
goal was a 355 ship Navy that's what he
pushed for he got to 300 it's now at 291
wow is that big enough to deter and if
necessary defeat an invasion Taiwan
China has the largest naval fleet in the
world they have 350 ships they'll have
400 ships in 2 years we won't even have
350 ships in two decades China has built
up their military it's not just Land Air
and sea they're doing cyber they're
doing artificial intelligence they're
doing space right America needs to
modernize our military we need to do
everything we can the first thing is you
go and you make sure you have the back
of backs of Ukraine that's why the
Taiwanese want us to support Ukraine
because they know that sends the biggest
message to China the second thing is we
go to China and we start being tough on
them no more sales of our American soil
to China and let's take back what
they've already stolen then you go and
you to the universities no more having
millions of dollars go to our
universities then we will go and end all
for formal trade relations with China
until they stop murdering Americans from
fenel something Ron is yet to say that
he's going to do and then we modernize
our military when we
streng when we modernize it with the
focus of cyber artificial intelligence
and space when we make sure that we have
the backs of our friends whether it's in
Israel whether it's in Ukraine and we
should be arming Taiwan make sure they
have the equipment they need make sure
they have the training they need now
there is nothing China fears more than
knowing that America will have taiwan's
back let's make sure that we show it by
making sure they have the equipment they
need ever have
hypers I'm much more concerned with us
advancing in space like let's dominate
space because ships are really going to
be more and more vulnerable over time
with drones and everything else
president G's ambition and if China's
able to be the world's leading
superpower that will affect you and your
family in ways that are going to be very
bad they will export authoritarianism
all around the world as the cost of
doing business they W post things like
social credit scores and internet
monitoring so this is to this generation
what theet the
wared plan get 355 ships at the end of
the first term 385 ships at the end of
the second term but we're going to have
a path to 600 ships over the next 20
years I think the future of freedom is
going to be determined in the Indo
Pacific we have a strategy not with mil
not just military but decoupling from
the economy and fighting them here at
home with their cultural you know
Ambassador Haley said somehow I wasn't
doing she welcomed them into South
Carolina gave them m land near a
military base wrote the Chinese
Ambassador a love letter saying what a
great friend they were that was like
their number one way to to do economic
development in Florida I banned China
from buying land in this St we kicked
out on our universities and we kicked
the confucious institutes out of our
universities we've recognized the threat
and we've
acted to fire his campaign yes that's
the biggest problem he was a fantastic
has been a fantastic Governor his
campaign has been just a disaster had he
done what has done which is don't offend
Trump voters don't offend Trump
supporters embrace them and attack the
corruption and attack the corruption and
he would be in such a different place
right now totally different if they put
Will Chamberlain in charge of his PR and
got rid of the existing
ones would have killed it I mean he'd be
doing such a great job running that
campaign in the midst of trying to back
our strongest Ally in eastern Europe
we've seeing our resources and our
Weaponry help degrade the Russian
military the Indo Pacific we have real
challenges the long-term threat the
long-term threat is China immediate
threat is our Southern Border in order
for us to have the military to fight
three different con continents at the
exact same time we are going to have to
invest heavily in our military but we're
also going to have to invest heavily in
an industrial base so that we can hit
our objectives from a military
perspective not only with our ships but
also with our air with our planes we are
so old as a military that in order for
us to re-calibrate we're going to have
to invest one of the things I do in my
ma in America strategy is we create more
than 4 million new jobs by having
high-tech manufacturing come back to
America decoupling from China so that we
focus our attention on creating that
Industrial Revolution that maybe you all
should have not fired unvaccinated
soldiers this Tim Scott should not be on
stage right now yeah no no keep him as
his Senator you know if if they want him
there in South Carolina seems like a
nice guy but he's so out of his how big
would the fleet get first answer is end
the toxic divest to invest program for
people who don't know about that we're
decommissioning ships in the South China
Sea the foundation of war is economics
rebuild our defense industrial base at
home but here's the Dirty Little Secret
our actual defense industrial base
depends on China for the supply chain
for the F-35 jets for the ships that
we're building think about this why are
we stockpiling that if it isn't to
actually be strong against our enemy
China we depend on them for that just
like we depend on them for
pharmaceuticals just like we depend on
them for semiconductors so here's why we
can't get tough with China it's because
we depend on them for our modern way of
life and we have to declare economic
independence from our enemy that's the
Declaration of Independence depence that
Thomas Jefferson at the age of 33 would
have signed and today if you were alive
that's the Declaration of Independence
that I will sign as the next president
you have to recognize Ronda s was corre
about acknowledging Nikki Haley's tough
talk when she was ambassador to the UN
calling China our great friend bringing
the CCP to South Carolina what he left
out though Ron and be honest about it
there was a lobbying based exemption in
that bill that allowed Chinese Nationals
to buy L within a 20m radius of a
military base lobbied for by one of your
donors so I think we have to call a
spade a spade we need politicians who
are independent of the forces that
increase our dependence on China my
message to shiin Ping is this you are
done buying land in this country you
will not donate to universities in this
country us businesses won't expand into
the Chinese market until you play by the
same set of
rules sounds like rules
for accountability for the co 19
pandemic financially unleash hell on the
world we have to hold them accountable
you have a number
increase our Naval capacity by at least
20% over the course of the next several
years be able to meet our Aus agreement
standards right now we are at risk of
not even being able to meet our Aus
standards with with Australia in the UK
so what we need to do is have a plan
that reverses the trajectory of the
divest to invest program 20% over the
next 3 years Governor Christie you know
my first observation Hugh is that nobody
answers your Hugh
my second observation is these three in
the middle think they're the enemy I
know China is the enemy and that's what
we should be focused on so let's be
really clear the nuclear submarines in
this United States Navy is the greatest
deterrent to Chinese aggression and that
is the first place I would go to
increase American Naval power our
nuclear submarines are able to move
stealthly quietly and effectively and if
we are going to deter China from
invading Taiwan the only way we're going
to do it is to make sure that they don't
know whether how many nuclear submarines
from the United States of America are in
the South China see and in that area and
ready to strike on them if they decide
to move on Taiwan and so we as our first
priority need to go directly to our
nuclear subprogram Hue and we need to
increase it drastically that would be
priority number one ships would come
next but to me the ships are secondary
Choice here the the submarines are the
single most important thing that we
could be deterring that we could using
to deter China the other thing we can do
to deter China is to let them know that
the blood money they're spending for
Russia in Ukraine right now will not be
effective that we send Putin home with
his tail between his legs and make them
understand that the same fate waits for
them if they decide to move towards
Taiwan with a more aggressive nuclear
subprogram we'll be able to make that
threat real thank you Governor we're
going to take a brief pause now and
we'll be back to the Republican presal
need more subs to have a a legitimate
threat uh nuclear threat I we we already
have Subs uh I don't think that it's a
terrible idea to have more nuclear subs
um Trump just won't play and keep in
mind the Chinese have nuclear subs on
our West Coast I don't think I don't
know if that's actually true I would be
shocked if they didn't were there more
people watching the Trump rally no no
7,700 and the GOP debate's about 70k but
I can't I it's probably because the it
won't play the dream won't play so wild
yeah yeah it we can uh start recycling
95% of our spent nuclear fuel through
closed system recycling systems and just
have so much more I mean nuclear
powerered submarines is definitely the
way with nuclear warheads ready nuclear
power in general is such a massive
opportunity for America they haven't
talked about graphine which we're going
to start if we're going to
reindustrialize our Navy it's going to
be with lightweight graphine materials
and hydrogen fuel and nuclear power
these are the things that none of them
got specific I know they're limited with
time and that's why president usually
has science advisers to advise them on
those things but we abely are you gun
for that job in yeah yeah yeah gunning I
like that metaphor yeah I'm going to
help the the US Navy become the greatest
on Earth I want ships that can go from
underwater into outer space and back
again oh I'm with you on that I see I
told you my concern is space you know as
long as we're able to get up there I'm
happy man super lightweight submarines
that can go up into orbit uh energy Tech
we need uh better propulsion technology
better better energy conversion
technology things like that yes yeah
like what plutonium no I don't defer the
the nuclear sub thatu that stuff's very
heavy remember nuclear subs are just you
know it's it's just a a it's just used
to heat water you know it's just a steam
engine so the the tech for nuclear sub
to make the the rotor spin is going to
be significantly different to what would
be necessary to actually have propulsion
that can defeat it's easy because
they're floating like pazo electric
power where you actually can vibrate
substrates to create electrical current
that's so you don't actually need steam
like that's the next step of energy
production I don't okay I don't I don't
know how that would trans trans out to
space it would be lighter weight than
having fuel on board or something or or
like hydrogen fuel well somebody already
knows how to do it have you guys seen
these videos uh from you know the UFO
files the government's been like slowly
putting out that some of these have gone
into the ocean they visually confirmed
like the pilots have seen them go into
the ocean and come out I mean somebody's
figured it out I know who it is I I
don't it's it's not hard to make a an
air and C vehicle yeah so we already
have planes that can land on uh uh on
water you could probably I don't think
it's a great feat of engineering to
figure out how to make something that's
to submerge it and then come back out
you know what I mean I think the speeds
they're doing it and everything is
really what they've been impressed by
the B that's the biggest problem is if
you're talking about getting into space
like breaking Earth's gravity is is
really really really hard yeah you know
you have to be it's 2,000 mph is the
speed you need to be to get out of Earth
gravity they've got those spin launch
systems have you seen those where
they'll get it's spinning really fast
and you can get materials up really easy
it slingshot basically spins around and
then boom straight up in the air that's
cool looks so cool and then another
thing they do is um they they they'll
bring a plane as high up as possible and
launch from the plane so that it cuts
down a lot of the energy usage But
ultimately the plan is get everything on
the moon you build a moon base this is
what it was this is the artus project
right yeah you build a moon base so that
you slowly transport energy and
materials up there and then you can
launch for further missions yeah they're
working on the space elevator on the
moon lift Port is the company with
Michael Lane he used to work at Nasa and
they're they're aiming at doing it on
the moon first because of the low
gravity it's easier to get the elevator
up and running and I think graphine is
going to be the material for the tether
or at least going be some sort of
graffing alloy or something they're
they're coming back to the debate here
we go who's the biggest loser so far Tim
Scott Scott yeah and then Christy and
welcome backr the big presential debate
once again here's Hugh huitt thank you
Lester we're going to stay on China and
we're going to talk specifically about
Tik Tock last week Congressman Mike
Gallagher who is Chairman of the house
bipartisan select committee on the
Chinese Communist Party published a long
essay on Tik Tok following the flooding
of pro Hamas propaganda on Tik Tok
accounts across the United States
chairman Gallagher called it shocking he
called the app predatory controlled by
America's preeminent adversary one to
push propaganda and divide America it's
spy wear he said a means of surveillance
governor chrisy do you agree with
chairman Gallagher and if so would you
ban or Force the sale of Tik Tock I
agree 100% with chairman Gallagher and
let me say this Tik Tock is not only spy
wear it is polluting the minds of
American young people all throughout
this country and they're doing it
intentionally and when you saw what
happened in the last few weeks if that's
true
all
anti-semitic horrible stuff that their
algorithms were pushing out at a
gargantuan rate I I believe that's true
is m g on the show the chairman so there
was a there was Data showing that
despite there being more Pro Palestine
posts they weren't getting very many
views and then a week later like on the
dot 10 x the views 100 x the views which
is more indicative of an algorithmic
boost to those posts 100% should have
and now since then we've had additional
nearly 6
years of this type of poison being put
out throughout the United States even
putting aside the Spy which we know is
going on in the theft of American
personal data and
information so in my first week as
President we would ban Tik Tock they
want to go ahead and sell it let them go
ahead and sell it but I'll tell you
another reason does the president
have China social media site X is not in
China it's because of TI
to information to the Chinese people
from oural in a certain way make them
free their software code to operate they
can't do that TI Tok
might poisoning American minds and I
would do it week one thank you Governor
I want to go to Governor would you ban
or Force the sale of Tik Tok regardless
of whether or not China allowed American
apps to operate in China yes I think
that China is the top threat we Face
they've been very effective at inating
different parts
of my policy on the Chinese Communist
part is very simple we win they lose and
in order to do that it's not just
military it's economic and it's cultural
and as the dad of a 65 and a
three-year-old I'm concerned about the
data that they're getting from our young
people and what they're doing to pollute
the minds of our young people these kids
get these devices and they have a mind
of their own and I know a lot of parents
are looking it's hard to even keep it
out out China's obviously the most
extreme but this is happening with other
things so we are going to do that and we
going to make sure to protect the
American people it's a full spectrum
approach to be able to fend China off
yes military deter
economic need to parent I have a
14-year-old she doesn't have Tik
Tok it's not and she doesn't want it she
doesn't want Tik Tok my kid got my my
nephews go to public school they're
they're not like you know tucked away my
sister's a norm bank manager she's as
Norm as you get the fact that two people
hit me and you didn't let me respond so
let's first talk it's probably because
she's from 10 years ago yes I brought a
fiberglass company 10 years ago to South
Carolina but Ron you are the chair of
your Economic Development agency that as
of last week said Florida is the ideal
place for Chinese businesses not only
that you have a company that is
manufacturer of Chinese
military you have it they are expanding
two training sites at two of your
airports now one which is 12 mil away
from a naval base then you have another
company that's expanding and they were
just invaded by the Department of
Homeland Security so mine was 10 years
ago give what's your story and I abolish
that agency that she's talking about
Enterprise Florida we abolished it and
of course we banned China from buying
land
them from
puring flid Mr R Swami uh we've talked
about this you campaign on Tik Tock how
do you get Tik Tock banned if you use it
well I I I want to laugh at why Nikki
Haley didn't answer your question which
is about looking at families in the eye
in the last debate she made fun of me
for actually joining Tik Tok while her
own daughter was actually using the app
for a long time so you might want to
take care of your family
first adult daughter the next generation
of Americans are using it and that's
actually the point your kid duding her
up that's what I just said wasn't it the
easy answer is actually to say that
we're just going to ban one app we got
to go further we have to ban any us
company actually transferring us data to
the Chinese here's a story most people
don't know Airbnb hands over us user
data to the CCP now that's a us-owned
company so this is the problem when you
have Republicans that temporarily go the
way the winds blow and now it's popular
to talk tough on China when she was UN
Ambassador called them literally her
words not mine our great friend you
can't be Fairweather fans of the right
policy get to the root cause even us
companies in Silicon Valley are
regularly doing it cut the virtue
signaling the fact of the matter is
Democrats are on Tik Tok today the only
person one of the few people who is
putting up content the way the actual
algorithms work speaking for pro-israel
views or others is
Republicans will join
it Chinese
comp you don't get to respond to
personal attacks but you do thank you
very much you know when he talks about
me praising China he doesn't know the
fact that the reason China was praised
was because I negotiated with China and
Russia the largest set of sanctions
against North Korea in a generation we
are the that is literally the reason
North Korea stopped testing ballistic
missiles so I said China did good on
their part
that was a negoti friend is what you
said Nikki those are your words not mine
it's just own up to it you would never
have been able to get
negotiation North Korea has had no
material effect on our
lived Nation every day I fought China
and I did it making sure no one could
get any agency heads in un I did it by
making sure that we called them out on
human rights I did it by making sure
that we held them accountable on
everything that they did that's the
reason we got out the Human Rights
Council that's the reason we called them
out and I have there's nothing to day I
haven't your exp made afterwards
everybody else is hanging on to the
rules here Mr ramaswami Senator Scott
thank you we should no no let's M it I
don't think you can I don't think you
can ban companies that interact how G to
muting his answers at this point if
you're constantly Banning companies that
interact with China you're going to be
chasing the tail always be right behind
the company that just did it and the
data is going to con so you need to
force them to open up the code ahead of
time so you can see which ones are
sending it and immediately cut it
off also should provide in my parents
Bill of Rights we give parents the
opport but he should not
there to be on those I think if the
people in a state are happy with it
let's stick with that I just want I just
want to say you guys know the story of
the the turtle and the rabbit or
whatever you know basically The Story
Goes that the turtle was really really
slow and the rabbit was chilling taking
it easy and then the turtle tried as
hard as it could but the rabbit just you
know scrolled across Finish Line and Tim
got the turtle so there you go pretty
sure that's how the story no no the
other way around the turtle won the race
cuz he never stopped know buying our
farmlands we talked about that several
times have to make sure that we use the
tools that are in our toolkit to stop
China from buying Farmland near our
bases the third thing we have to do is
make sure that they stop stealing our
intellectual property they're literally
steal I got to say something um I've had
people tell me cuz like we watch this
stuff we'll read news stories and I'll
you know like I like I'm muting Tim
Scott and then people will be like hey
but you know like what if you want to
get him on the show at some point I'm
like dude I've had people ask me about
this with prominent people like oh but
if you criticize them like what if they
don't come on your show I'm like I guess
they don't come on my show I guess we
don't get the biggest show in the world
I'm not gonna you know play this game
and and and some of the bigger shows are
willing to do it less partisan ones
they'll absolutely be like I I don't
want to be too mean to somebody because
they're hoping they can book them later
I know what you mean because it could it
could help everybody if we get Tim Scott
in the room are able to like talk some
sense
himal you're just going to get very
boilerplate
politicals they're never willing to go
past and I think that's really that is
the future of America if we're going to
save this country it's going to be that
we have a whole lot more truth tellers
who are willing to have hard
conversations who are willing to act
like normal people and not go robot who
finds this attractive in our generation
nobody these people are living off the
politics of the9 and it's how our
generation
think that's why's doing this create job
we're going to lower energy costs but
we're also going to be more energy
independent and secure we'll choose
Midland over Moscow we'll choose the
marcelis over the mulas and we'll choose
bachan over Beijing that is good for
America's national security Biden's
Green New Deal that's good for Venezuela
it's good for Russia it's good for Iran
and it's good for China so I would turn
the screws on the Venezuelan regime I
think it's a corrupt dictatorial regime
and we should never go hat in hand
begging for oil from them just to be
clear would you reimpose the sanctions
yes absolutely Ambassador Haley what
would your approach be you know I stood
on the salimon boulevard bridge and
watch thousands of Venezuelans cross in
the for hours in the hot sun holding
their babies to get the one meal they
might get that day going from Venezuela
to Colombia they were fleeing socialism
and begging for Freedom we need to make
sure that we do everything we can to
sanction Maduro we shouldn't be getting
dirty oil and Biden just gave 500,000
Venezuelans temporary priority status
which is just going to have more of them
come but on the energy side it cracks me
up that Ron continues to do this he has
opposed fracking he's opposed drilling
last time he said it wasn't true and
everybody found out that it was true he
opposed it before Florida voters even
voted on it he was praised by the Sierra
Club and you're trying to make up for it
and act like you weren't you weren't a
liberal when it comes to the environment
you were you always have been just own
it if that's the case but don't keep
saying you're something that you're not
let me respond to that um resp so uh our
whole energy plan you can't get the
Shale without fracking we are absolutely
going to Frack but I disagree with Nikki
Haley I don't think it's a good idea to
drill in the Florida Everglades and I
know most Floridians agree with me you B
fracking thank you very much Lester all
right all thank you let's turn to one
the new Florida uh in Florida it's very
clear nobody wants the Everglades drill
that's been a long time thing both
parties
everybody without breaking the bank
you've all said the best way to deal
with Rising prices is to cut government
spending but that would take time to
play out and Americans are struggling
right now Senator Scott I'll start with
you what would you do
there we go that's I'll get a drink be
good if any of them knew what a real
family struggling my mother was a single
mother who raised me and my brother in a
very challenging economic situation the
first thing I can tell you is that when
your gas prices are 40% higher right now
than they were just a little over two
years ago that's not a problem for my
mama that was a crisis the first thing I
would do is pres the United States is I
would sign the XL Keystone Pipeline and
start seeing resources flow second thing
I would do is make sure that there's
certainty and predictability so that
those folks who have the leases in our
country would have the certainty and
predictability to go ahead and become
energy independent we should focus not
just on being energy independent we
should focus on being energy dominant
America is the home to more energy
resources than any other country on the
planet we can reduce the price of energy
we can reduce the price of food and the
price of electricity if we focus on my
build here don't borrow from China plan
that has embedded the made in America
strategy cre 10 million new jobs in
three different areas one is innovation
second is the high-tech manufacturing
and the third is the energy economy we
have an opportunity As Americans to
actually export their Surplus
energy that we create new rule any
debate requires a random Tradesman from
a random part of the country who's got
to be between the ages of like 30 and 50
to be on that stage at the same time as
all the politicians who's not running
yeah that would be amazing the most
uranium comes out of Canada Australia
kazakstan Russia has the largest
enrichment program and get a lot from
them some like let's just say you got
like a 40-year-old like I don't know
plumber on that stage they'd be like the
thing about Vladimir Putin and these and
the Baltic states he'd be like what the
you talking about I'm trying to get gas
for my kids to go to school what is this
yeah yep 100% when you allow for those
who have leases to actually start
drilling to start using those leases for
for more energy excavation you put our
economy in the strongest position and as
a result of that prices start going down
that is the kind of economy that as
president of the United States I would
lead this nation to making sure that we
first use the resources in our own
country and not going outside of our
country this all nobin stuff I don't
understand like who's innovating
something who's going to do something
really impressive yeah rice Unity I got
to say when I when I tweeted James tour
I tweeted holy F Dick Cheney and 3inch
Hills VI roasts Nikki Haley everyone's
like you think he was talking about Ron
like Luke Luke tweeted you sure that
wasn't about Ron everyone saying the
same thing Senator thank you let me let
me ask the same question to Governor d
sanis can you give us some you ticked
off a number of things a moment ago but
some specific examples of ways that
would would people on a a better
economic footing right away so I started
off working minimum wage jobs I did $6
an hour as an electrician's assistant I
worked all kinds of things to be able to
get through school and I did that
because I believed in America if you
work hard and get the most out of your
god-given ability you can get ahead and
what's happening now many of you are
working hard and you're falling further
and further behind I've met people
people in Iowa New Hampshire and all
across the country who've talked about
all the burdens that they're facing with
the rising prices and I've heard from
multiple people the same story when they
go grocery shopping what they now do is
they figure out what they have to take
out of the cart once it's ringing up
because it rings up so much faster and
so much higher at the cash register that
they can't afford the full card of
groceries anymore we have to restore the
American dream in this country what can
you do on day one here's what I'm going
to do I'm going to take all the
executive orders the regulations
everything involving bionomics I'm going
to rip it up and I'm going to throw it
in the trash can on day one where it
belongs that is going to give the
economy breathing room and I'm also
going to rein in the Federal Reserve
they have help create uh with their
Reckless monetary policy what we have
faced since the co 19 pandemic they
botched it Congress botched it both
parties are to blame fed should focus on
stable prices they are not an economic
Central planner for the American people
Governor thank you Mr R weigh in ways
you can improve people's Financial in
the short term as a CEO the economic
question is core to my vision and policy
prescription for this country increase
the supply of everything it's the law of
supplies and demand increase the supply
of energy that brings down the cost of
energy grows the economy drill Frack
burn coal Embrace nuclear increase the
supply of labor in this country stop
using our tax taxpayer money to pay
people more to stay at home instead of
to go to work increase the supply of
housing people don't talk about this
when in the Republican Party the land
use restrictions are constricting the
supply of housing that's making housing
more expensive for ordinary Americans
across so that's the true answer and I
think it takes a CEO in the White House
who actually understands this to get
this done because Americans at home they
know the bomic is a lie prices are going
up interest rates and mortgages to buy
your home are going up but wages have
remained flat that's the hard diagnosis
for our economy and this is about more
than just our economy I say this as a
member of my generation I'm 38 years old
I'm the youngest person ever to run for
US president as a republican the reason
my generation has lost our sense of
national pride in part is because people
in my generation feel like the American
dream isn't available to them and part
of the reason why is we've burdened them
with four-year college degrees that did
not serve their head start on the
American dream people will be more proud
of a country if we're all making more
money in that country this is how we
revive national pride and our identity
and it will take a CEO in the white
house with zerob based budgeting by the
way to take on the
federal turn to governor chrisy on that
I tweeted at Luke hey Luke uh can you
see Ron's shoes he said not yet but
we'll send a picture soon I was going to
ask him to scream out graphing
absolutely energy is the key to this
because it drives every one of those
other prices you know now food gets to
your grocery store it gets trucked
and those truckers have to pay for fuel
for the higher fuel prices and when you
go ahead and you tell people we are
going to unleash every bit of American
Energy every bit of its potential what
happens in the Futures markets the
prices go down because those people who
are believing that the Biden program
will continue are the ones who are
bidding this up and let me tell you the
other place that's bidding it up in the
Middle East and so if you don't believe
that making sure that Israel and that
Israel situation that's going on right
now is it resolved and resolved quickly
as president of the United States and
bring stability back that will also not
permit countries like Saudi Arabia and
others to be able to jack their prices
as well and what they say is a response
to crisis when it's really what it's in
response to is putting more money in
their pockets when they have American
president who knows that Israel must be
defended not with humanitarian pauses
and not with suggestions for ceasefire
but with letting them know we will
supply them with everything they need
that will also bring stability to the
market energy is the key to bringing
this down it's what every American
family needs when they turn on their
lights fill up their car and go to the
grocery store and we need to do that
first and foremost that's the short-term
answer energy
like I did a killer video M yesterday he
wants to reuse spent Fuel and thorium
salt on my YouTube
channel I like what Chris chrisy was
saying about grocery stores because I
appreciate when a man talks about what
they're really an expert in that he is
an expert at grocery bills well I'm a
product of Ral America I grew up in
rural South Carolina and I can tell you
what we're seeing now in America is the
rich are getting richer and the poor are
getting poor we have to go start beefing
up the middle class and the first thing
I would do is I will eliminate the
federal um gas and Diesel tax going to
say mdle class but we have to stop
spending binge that's happening by
Republicans and Democrats in Congress I
will make sure one we claw back the $500
billion do of unspent coid dollars that
are out there instead of 87,000 IRS
agents going after Middle America we'll
go after the hundreds of billions of
dollars of Co fraud that exist one out
of we'll stop the spending we'll stop
the borrowing we'll eliminate the
earmarks and I'll veto any spending bill
that doesn't go back to pre-co levels
that will cut trillions and allow us to
be safe we also need to be not energy
independent an energy dominant we are
blessed with resources let's do it but
the reason no one should give you a
number Hue on the amount of ships in the
Navy is because in a few years our
interest expense is going to be more
than our defense budget so no one can
give you that number realistically
without first tackling what's happening
with the financial situation it would be
a false number to give you that we have
got to understand this is a crisis it is
a national sec concern if we don't deal
with what's going to happen with that
interest expense in a few years we're
going to look like Japan and we can't
let that happen the strong dollar
matters Ambassador thank you very much
chrisan Americans could
see Americans could see their social
security benefits drastically cut in the
next decade because the program is
running out of money former president
Trump has said quote under no
circumstances should Republicans cut
entitlements Governor chrisy first to
you you have proposed rais in the
retirement age for younger Americans
what would that age be specifically and
would you consider making any other
reforms to Social Security sure and we
have to deal with this problem now look
if we raise the retirement age a few
years for folks that are in their 30s
and 40s um I have a son who's in the
audience tonight is 30 years old if he
can't adjust to a fewe increase in
Social Security retirement age over the
next 40 years I got bigger problems with
him than his soci Security payments are
there any Millennials that have a
retirement plan obviously almost none
almost none and the fact that these
people can sit up there on stage and say
we need to spend our money in Ukraine to
kill young Ukrainian men and women at
the same time as they tell us we need to
wait longer to retire than they did or
they par did no I'm good I I I'm
finished with these people's foreign
policy it's what got us here their
policies got us here shame on you you
shouldn't be taking the money there are
a lot of programs in this country that
we all pay for that we don't get a
direct benefit from Food Stamps is one
of them I've never fortunately in my
life ever had me or my family on F but
I'm glad it's there two different states
so that no one in this country goes to
bed hungry at night if they have
availability to that program but I don't
get a direct benefit the fact is on
Social Security remember why it was
established it was established as a
safety net program to make sure that no
one would grow old in this country in
poverty that's what we got to get back
to rich people should not be collecting
social Governor can you give me a
specific age 6970 what would the age be
no look that's going to be a part of a
negotiation with Congress C start
negotiating until I get there all right
Ambassador Haley let me have you weigh
in on this because you said in June that
you would be open to raising the
retirement age have you determined what
that age would be specifically and what
other reforms are you looking at so
first of all any candidate that tells
you that they're not going to take on
entitlements is not being serious Social
Security will go bankrupt in 10 years
Medicare have Ron and Trump joining
Biden and Pelosi saying they're not
going to change or do any sort of
entitlement reform what we need to do is
keep our promises those that have been
promised should keep it but for like my
kids in their 20s you go and you say
we're going to change the rules you
change the retirement
agrees we prom based on inflation we
should limit limit benefits on the
wealthy Bernie Marcus can tell you he
hates getting that check limit the
benefits on the we wealthy and then
expand Medicare Advantage plans seniors
love that and let's make sure we do that
so that they can have more competition
That's How we'll deal with entitlement
reform and that's how we'll start to pay
down this debt and can you give me a
specific age have you determined the age
again you have to work with Chris what I
can tell you is you can it's going to be
those in their 20s just coming into the
system and it should reflect more of
life expectancy it doesn't do that now
all right Mr ramaswami have you
determined if you would touch
entitlements and social security what if
any reforms are you looking at so this
is really important right now we're
working within the last window I believe
we will have to actually fix this
problem while still leaving Social
Security and Medicare benefits for
current seniors intact I'll tell you how
the other candidates assume like Nikki
that it can't be done and on her math
she's right about it but her math
assumes $7 trillion of our $33 trillion
national debt going to fight Wars like
in places like Iraq and Afghanistan
minus that our national debt would be
$26 trillion right now then you go to
zerob based budgeting which I've
proposed as a CEO it's how I've run
businesses it's how many CEOs run
businesses don't use last year's budget
as the Baseline start with zero as the
Baseline and then ask what's actually
necessary 75% headcount reduction yes
that is severe in the number of federal
employees in
theht what are these people they
agencies that should not exist deliver
economic growth as a positive Tailwind I
think we can get to three four maybe
even 5% GDP growth if we really take the
regulatory shackles off of our economy
and against that backdrop I believe this
is our last best window to be able to
take care of our national debt problem
through those severe measures including
sacrificing the Foreign Wars that many
bloodthirsty members of both parties
have a hunger for that's the one secret
for how we're going to be a to do this
that requires discipline so we can't
have the first conversation we were
having sending foreign aid willy-nilly
to countries whose national debt per
capita is less than ours but if we do
this correctly I think this is our last
window and it'll take a CEO from the
Next Generation to do it thank you very
much way in here you looking at you can
fix this problem for young people but
you have to be Innovative bot line is a
simple one we have to grow our economy
we're not doing that cheap energy cheap
fuel I actually was pulling this up uh
we can use our Navy to recover the
plastic and the Pacific gy are you guys
fam with the Pacific Garbage Patch this
thing the size of Texas
CRA but it's not dense yeah uh boy and
slat has something called the oce the
ocean cleanup project where they take
boats out with large tethers and they
let the ocean filter itself into it then
they recollect it that way BR it back to
from the US either yeah and so we can
actually steal it I mean you maybe
consider stealing it with our Navy but
we go recover it first then we flash
Jewel it turn it into graine and
hydrogen fuel and then we can a
retrofitter economy interesting that's
happened actually is that a bacteria has
emerged that eats plastic yeah
nature finds a w there's a fungus called
pestol opsis microspore spor that breaks
it down into sugar and there is also
bacteria that breaks it down you know I
think I think we have a problem in our
country that we have all these very
smart people very Innovative amazing
people and we use absolutely none of
them to do incredible amazing things
it's all in private business our
government does nothing so like don't
hope for them to go do this and steal
this with the Navy and turn it into
energy because they're not interested in
being Innovative in any way it's crazy
to me how correct VI is yet we have
these four other people who are just
like well how about we go blow people up
and it's just like VI's like we got the
the the zero budgeting from zero basic
business principle basic laying people
off I'm sorry sacrificing our form I
love that line no we just don't do them
you got all these people who are like
why do I have to retire later oh because
we sent billions of dollars to Ukraine
have a nice day exactly and Afghanistan
and Iraq right and all these other
places by the way there's all these
other places that we're involved in
spending tons of money in that we don't
even talk about like Syria we've spent a
ton of money in Syria we' spent money in
Libya we spent money in Africa all over
the place to get no discernable anything
for the American people the line that
that Vivic started with early the the
spent trillions killed millions and made
billions for themselves like that is
that's a really good line and it sums it
up very nicely in in a way that most
people can understand it's true thank
you Senator I appreciate it Governor
just s
finally raising the retirement agent how
would you keep Social Security
sustainable well look as governor of
Florida uh I know a few people on Social
Security and um I know it's important my
grandmother lived till 91 and Social
Security was her sole source of income
and that's true for a lot of seniors
throughout this country so I'd say to
seniors in America uh promise made
promise kept I understand what you're
going through with the rising prices uh
and you need that social security check
so we'll make sure to get that done uh
what can you do to help sh up Social
Security one of the things that's that's
causing problems is the inflation we
have to reduce inflation when you have
higher inflation the seniors get a cost
of living adjustment which means the
program is spending more but it doesn't
cover the increase in the actual
inflation rate we also do need to get to
at least 3% growth you're never going to
be able to have uh issues be able to
solve the budget without that but I
would note this Congress for decades
took money from Social Security Social
Security would have more tax revenue
that it put out they would take it and
then they'd write an IOU to Social
Security Congress has a lot of dirty
hands on this I'm going to f Force
Congress to stop spending so much money
um and you know one thing we have to we
talk about the retirement ages there
something that's changed in the last
four or five years life expectancy in
the United States is declining so govern
yes or no would you raise it would you
raise the retire when uh when life
expectancy is declining I don't see how
you could raise it the other direction
so it's one thing to Peg it on life
expect
but we have had a significant decline in
life expectancy in this country and
that's just the fact all right Governor
de santis thank you thank you candidates
and we will be that was a more political
did you hear what is what is this uh n w
tweeted an old man shot two climate
activists who are blocking a highway in
Panama yep is that true I can't find I I
see the picture but I I don't see any
sources I haven't heard of this yeah he
he got into a a dispute he literally
walked up to him and he pulled out the
gun he's like get out of the road
essentially how good is the ESS account
yeah they're pretty good pretty good
they're really pretty good stuff yeah
and wokeness my friend tweeted but I
need a new source on this one uh I don't
know I I've seen it uh shared by
multiple people he was arrested um I've
seen uh I don't know which website
actually or which Twitter account I
actually has a has the video of it um
but I retweeted about it a little bit
the the shooting there's video of it not
of him not I don't know if there's video
of him actually shooting there's the
video photo of him holding the gun
holding a gun and confronting them
there's video of him talking to people
but I don't know if there if anyone got
the video of the actual shots being
fired
wow I'm searching for it right now I
mean people are really getting fed up
with climate activists es especially as
more people oh yeah here's the video
more people kind of there's video of it
not of the shooting
oh oh man he whoa yeah this is real yeah
he pulls the gun
out wow wow this is crazy he's in
custody one person died on the scene and
one person died later uh I believe at
the hospital or on the weight look man
nonviolent civil disobedience is a good
way to create pressure but the cops got
to arrest the people who do it yeah yeah
you can't just allow them yeah the
videos the video is all cut cuz they
have footage of him doing yeah someone
tweeted that that there is video of him
actually doing the shooting out there
that's terrible nah you know these
people these people are irritating but
you can't kill them I mean that's
I I actually I I I respect non violence
of Disobedience if they want to go and
sit in front of a road that's the that's
the kind of pressure we should expect
otherwise I'd rather that than antifa
exactly that's my point the police
should come and arrest them and remove
them and restore the flow of traffic but
people need an opportunity to put
pressure on the system without resorting
to violence about arrest no because I
agree with that too I do I absolutely
but that's just a situation where you're
going to end up with with confrontations
and violence anyway so I would say it
should be limited because there are
limited scenar scarios where I think
that could make sense doing citizens
arrests where you know somebody like
I'll put it this way if I had a family
member whose life was in danger and they
needed to get to the hospital and
there's Climate Pro uh all citizens
arrest them I'll do whatever is
necessary to get my family member to the
hospital yo there's there's straight
video of it dude in Panama it happened
in Panama and the dude is just standing
there he's not attacking or anything the
guy just shoots him that's terrible yeah
yeah there's no excuse for like I do
think you're absolutely right Tim this
is probably the form of protest we
should have to you know say we're okay
with this because the alternative is
this really crazy stuff you got to have
some outlet for rest yeah do you see the
video of the shoplifter getting tackled
and then he's like you can't touch me
the GU like you're being touched yeah
what what state was that in I don't know
man it was California he's right you
can't touch them you know awes no uh
it's not it's not the law that matters
there's a lot of laws in the books that
we don't enforce yeah like women can't
go sky diving on Sundays in Florida is
the gag one but if someone's shoplifting
like hundreds of dollars of the merch
and someone who works there stops them
they go you can't touch me it's like
talk to a judge yeah get a ass sue me
and then see what the judge says but it
it really is it's going to be I I think
I don't think it's it's not illegal to
stop someone stealing it's a civil uh
issue
yeah the craziest thing I remember from
California is they had that case where
the guy shot the robber came into his
house and they actually ruled in favor
of the robber who when they sued the
homeowner oh wow crazy and they made him
pay the
robber yes welcome back to tonight's NBC
News Republican presidential debate once
again here's Salem Radio Hugh hu thank
you much when NBC News talks to voters
when I talk to voters every day they all
say that the border is a top issue it
can mean a lot of different things it
can mean 2 million people who crossed
illegally last year it can mean more
than 150 arrest rest of people on the
terror watch list it can mean the burden
on States from having migrants move into
their States from the southwestern
border but I want to talk about opioids
specifically and Fentanyl and I'll start
with you Senator Scott tens of thousands
of Americans families have suffered a
death to fentanyl young people sometimes
die taking one pill what can you do as
commander-in-chief on the first day to
stop Fentanyl and the waterfall it into
this country number one we should close
our Southern border for10 billion we
could close our Southern border for an
additional $5 billion we could use the
currently available military technology
to surveil our Southern border to stop
fitl from crossing our border I've
already LED on legislation that is
sanction would sanction the Mexican
cartels if you remember the path the
precursors come from China then they are
manufactured in Mexican labs and then
the Mexican cartels bring them across
our border by sanctioning their accounts
and eliminating their cash we starve
them with what they need number one
closing our Southern border makes it
nearly impossible to get in the military
grade technology is a backup making sure
that we not only stop
70,000 deaths in the last 12 months
because of fentol it also allows us to
deal trafficking travesty that is
entering in our country in the same path
if we are going to deal effectively with
a 100,000 overdose deaths in our country
70,000 that is directly linked to fol we
have to deal with our ports of entry and
deal with our Southern border if we do
that effectively we have started
reducing The Challenge from the outside
and then we have to deal with the
challenge on the inside which seems to
be connected how long have we all been
crisis that is spreading throughout our
nation if you solve the problem you'll
have to still solve the problem
somewhere else you vote for me I'll
solve problem I mean it gets frustrating
being right so far ahead of the
government and these people and then
they say things like it's like some
shocking
idea we've all been waiting the American
people have been waiting for a very long
time nobody's doing anything about it I
don't believe them is to not become
sarcastic when you're right all the time
don't don't allow yourself to start to
become sarcastic CU I think that works
against it
changes sign an that would send the
National Guard to partner with Customs
and Border Patrol both at ports of entry
and at the open ports of our border
Customs and Border Patrol agents are
overwhelmed there's 200,000 encounters a
month over the last 11 months we simply
do not have the man and woman power at
the border to be able to deal with it
and so dealing with both law enforcement
and and you're right right we have done
this we can do this but we got to give
them the tools to do it and technology
is one of the biggest tools that we
don't have enough of at the ports of
Entry now we also need to lower demand
you in this country and the way to lower
demand is to start treating people again
you know we started to do this before
coid and we haven't done enough of it
and for every family out there tonight
who has lost a loved one to fentanyl or
to any other type of opioid overdose
what you know is all you want is a
chance for them to win their lives back
when I'm president of the United States
we're going to call this what it is it
is a disease like heart disease diabetes
or any other disease like cancer that
can be treated should be treated we not
only have to stop Supply but we have to
lower demand and safe than you governor
governor Dan santis you have
talked about using United States Special
Forces to attack the cartels where they
manufacture the chemicals that come from
China how often how many what it what
does that look like well first I was
speaking to a dad who lost a son
fentanyl overdose son wasn't a drug
addict he had taken some pill that
happened to be laced with fentanyl and
it was a fatal overdose and what he told
me obviously the pain of losing a child
is as bad as it gets but he said what
was salt in the wounds is that these
Elites in DC don't give a damn about
what's going on in this country they
don't care that we have tens of
thousands of opioid deaths that the
fenel pouring in they are not taking the
type of action we need to we're
declaring it a National Emergency on day
one I'm sending US military to the
Border I'm going to stop The Invasion
cold I am going to deport people who
came illegally and I'm even going to
build the border wall and have Mexico
pay for it Like Donald Trump promis how
you going to do it yeah Mexico is not
going to Fork over money we're going to
impose fees on the remittances that
foreign workers send to foreign
countries we raise billions of dollars
I'll build a wall but we are going to
designate the cartels to be foreign
terrorist organizations or something
similar to that and we're going to
authorize the use of deadly force we're
going to have maritime operations to
interdict precursor chemicals going into
Mexico but I'll tell you this if someone
in the drug cartels is sneaking fencing
all across the border when I'm present
that's going to be the last thing they
do we're going to shoot him stone cold
dead I just realized we can build the
wall out of
graphing if Ambassador haly if the
United States uses special forces in
Mexico without prior notice to the
Mexican allies to our South what would
your the United Nations think about that
I don't care what my colleagues at the
United Nations think what I'll tell you
is the United Nations is useless you
have to go to the source we have lost
more Americans than the Vietnam Afghan
Afghanistan and Iraq Wars combined we
lost 75,000 Americans last year go to
the source it is the reason why we will
continue to say we will end all normal
trade relations with China until they
stop murdering Americans you watch how
quick that flow stops the second thing
is we'll send Special Operations in to
take out the cartels we need to go to
where they're Distributing it where the
Supply Centers are and take them out
we'll put 25,000 more border patrol and
Ice agents on the ground and let them do
their job we will defund Sanctuary
cities we will go back to the remain in
Mexico policy so that everybody stays in
Mexico and they never get here in the
first place and instead of catching to
Port we'll go to Catch and Release
instead of Catch and Release we'll go to
catch and way we'll deal with the Border
those are the things that we have to do
going forward but I do agree with Chris
one of the first things that we have to
do is really focus on mental health and
addiction centers it is something that
is needed in our country terribly
because we don't deal with mental health
and someone who doesn't get care for
mental health falls into addiction and
we owe it to them to treat it like the
cancer that it is ramaswami IA it's
really hard
we're talking about this issue is you
know like Ron I've actually met many
parents across this country who have
lost their kids to laced Pharmaceuticals
that have fentel in them the only thing
I would ask R I think you'd be on the
same page with me on this let's not even
call that an overdose right that is not
an
overdose that is poisoning if you put
that fentanyl in a Big Mac we would not
call that an overdose you'd call it what
it is it's closer to biot terrorism and
I say that because as it uniquely
relates to this crisis that does warrant
more aggressive means to deal with it so
there's a new presidential election in
Mexico in 2024 people may not be aware
of that it's going to be someone other
than oor who has been a disaster in
Mexico I think he's even mentioned me
obliquely in speeches to say that
somebody who would do this shouldn't get
anywhere near the White House well amlo
get out of the way there's going to be
someone else in charge I hope that build
a good relationship with that next
president of Mexico we'll use our our
own military to seal our own Southern
border what we need to do is stop using
our military to protect somebody else's
border Halfway Around the World when
we're short right here at home get
serious about protecting this border and
then the other thing that hasn't been
discussed is the northern border I'm the
only candidate on the stage as far as
I'm aware who has visited the northern B
there was enough fentanyl that was
captured just on the northern border
last year to kill million
Americans where the not just where the
is don't just build
the wuse the military to seal the SSS
cheese for the tunnels that they're
actually building underneath that
wall get this job done we need a wall
for the map curtain
up so
far right supporters saw victories in
Ohio Virginia should wi in States like
Kansas and Kentucky Governor Dan santis
first to you how do you see the path
forward for Republicans on this issue
well I stand for a culture of life and
uh I understand that it's important that
everyone get a shot I'm reminded of a
story about a a young mother who was
struggling in Jamaica about 40 years ago
45 years ago she was counseled to to not
have a baby because she was poor baby
wouldn't have opportunity and she came
close to have an abortion but she
decided to have the baby born poor in
Jamaica and the reason I know that story
is because that baby girl ended up
immigrating to the state of Florida uh
becoming a lawyer and a judge and I
appointed her to the Florida Supreme
Court in August of 2022 we better off
when everybody counts uh we're better
off when we can promote a culture of
Life at the same time I understand that
some of these states are doing it a
little bit different Texas is not going
to do it the same as New Hampshire Iowa
is not necessarily going to do it the
same as Virginia so you got to work from
the bottom up uh you got to do a better
job on these referenda I think of all
the stuff that's happened to the
pro-life cause uh they have been caught
flat-footed on these referenda and they
have been losing the referenda a lot of
the people who are voting for The
referenda are Republicans who would vote
for a republican candidate so you got to
understand how to do that but let's just
be clear the Democrats have taken a
position they will not identify the
point at which there should be any
protection all the way up until birth
that is wrong and we cannot stand for
that all right Governor D santis thank
you Ambassador Haley let me have you
weigh in former president Trump has
consistently blamed the abortion issue
and how Republican candidates have
talked about it for their electoral
losses how do you see the path forward
you I've said it before I think you have
to be honest with the American people
this is a personal issue for every woman
and every man I am unapologetically
pro-life not because the Republican
Party tells me to be but because my
husband Michael was adopted and I had
trouble having both of my children so
I'm surrounded by blessings having said
that when you look post row a wrong was
made right they took it out of the hands
of unelected justices and they put it in
the hands of the people and now we're
seeing States vote and what I'll tell
you is as much as I'm pro-life I don't
judge anyone for being pro-choice and I
don't want them to judge me for being
pro-life so when we're looking at this
there are some states that are going
more on the pro-life side I welcome that
there's some states that are going more
on the pro-choice side I wish that
wasn't the case but the people decided
but when it comes to the federal law
which is what's being debated here be
honest it's going to take 60 Senate
votes a majority of the house and a
president to sign it so no we haven't
had 60 Senate votes in over a hundred
years we might have 45 pro-life Senators
so no Republican president can ban
abortions any Democrat president can ban
these state laws so let's find consensus
let's agree on what how we can ban late
term abortions let's make sure we
encourage adoptions and good quality
adoptions let's make sure we make
contraception accessible let's make sure
that none of these state laws put a
woman in jail or give her the death
penalty for getting an abortion let's
focus on how to save as many babies as
we can and support as many moms as we
can and stop the Judgment we don't need
to divide America over this issue
anymore there's a lot of weakness there
there's a lot of weakness in some of the
things she said that is just stating out
of it however I do think that she is
being honest about the fact that Fally
nothing's going to happen you don't have
the votes no Republican president is
going to have the votes to do anything
ferally so it's aot question it belongs
in the states the problem is aree it's a
federal question do
think human rights are a con federal
constitutional question not a state
question a state does not have the right
to determine that a person for a certain
reason is not is not granted human
rights I would agree with that however
if you can't do anything and the status
quo is what it is what do you do well
that's actually the uh the roow row
standard was that it was a a question of
the federal government to determine
whether or not a baby was alive and they
came to the determination that that post
viability there's really no question but
it's it's much more complicated than I'd
be able to answer to right now my point
is
simply if we allow the federal if we
allow the state to determine who is
deserving of Human Rights then buckle up
California oh yeah no I know I mean
that's sort of the the really amazing
thing about Federalism is that people
will get to see naturally what the end
result of the democrat's ideology is in
a place like California because if you
just say hey we're going to take a more
Federalist approach we're going to say
State's rights is just the end all be
all California will turn into hell and
maybe that's what their voters need to
see abortion is a pro-choice position
like a video when you're saying that in
California they're allowed to get
abortions whenever they want that's
that's a that's like a that's a national
pro-choice position in my op I don't
want them to I'm just saying in
reality the federal government never
going to do anything about local
jurisdictions can decide whether or not
they allow abortions or not or you say
abortions are banned that's my point
yeah so when when a lot of people on the
right are like yes it's a state question
State question it's like that's kind of
pro-choice of you to say well if you
vote for it you can do it I think it's
just realistic because we know we don't
have the votes we know we don't have 60
Senators who are going to get on board
it's not just about the votes it's the
fact that honestly like it's not the
idea of a Banning abortion totally is
not popular enough and it's a loser and
as long as Republicans are out there
saying that they want to ban abortion on
any level even for local stuff that's
going to translate not to just the
specific areas but that's what's people
are going to think broadly about the
Republican party if we elect Republicans
there will be abortion bans and they're
going to continue to lose the answer is
for Republicans to say we think the
government should help facilitate
abortions for anyone who wants it and
then look dead at the Liberals and say
do you need help yeah we got the we got
the president speaking honestly where he
stood and I think you should be honest
not making a political calculus but to
say if a bill is served up would you
sign it here's my view on this speaking
as a man they say men have trouble
speaking on this issue I don't think we
need to be that way it was my home state
of Ohio I'm upset about this yesterday
that passed a constitutional amendment
that now effectively codifies a right to
abortion all the way up to the time of
birth without parental consent why
that the Republicans did not
have or Vision onally irresponsive I
know Ohio is born raised and I live
there it's representative of the country
if in the state of Ohio we talk about
access to contraception adoption and
also here's the missing ingredient in
this movement sexual responsibility for
men we live in an era of reliable
genetic paternity tests that are 100%
reliable so we can say men deserve more
responsibility so we can tell women
we're all in this together it's not
men's rights versus women's rights it's
about human rights and I come back to
that case that Clarence Thomas spoke of
a pregnant woman walking down the street
she's assaulted the unborn child dies in
that assault you find me one person in
this country who says that that criminal
does not deserve liability for that
death you won't find one yep that says
we share the same instincts on this
issue but we require I believe a
different generation leadership to
actually lead us forward and unite the
country on this with honesty thank you
Mr
r federal limit in places like Tennessee
you know as much as I've heard people
saying abortion is unpopular in a place
like Tennessee you know being pro-life
is very popular it is broadly popular to
protect babies lives you know and it
should be everywhere the problem is the
Republican party is not taking a real
stance it's all over the place I kind of
want to prove sentience of the fetus if
you could somehow use a neural net or
something to see the intelligence in
these things when month we should show
high school students what an actual
they could watch the proced where a baby
is ripped Li and
suck they would have a big issue with it
you've seen these videos where you can
watch them on YouTube where somebody has
shown this who say they're 100% pro
choice they have no problem with
abortion they watch the video they go
pale as a ghost and they change their
view on the spot from
can't mother at risk in my home state of
New Jersey it goes up to 9 mon since you
get an abortion I find that morally
reprehensible but that is what the
people of our state have voted for and
we should not shortcircuit that process
until every State's people have the
right to weigh in on it but here's the
bigger issue Kirsten the bigger issue is
and Tim began to touch on this we're not
pro-life for the whole life to be
pro-life for the whole life means that
the life of a 16-year-old drug addict on
the floor of the County lockup is
precious and we should get treatment for
her to restore her life the 52y old
who's drug addicted should make sure
that any of his children who he's passed
that Addiction on to are treated well
too pro life not just in the womb
Kirsten it's for the whole life what
he's doing right now is actually gived
to Democrats what they've said for many
years I mean this is the definition of
cowardice on display when you go and you
feed into what the Democrats have lied
and said about every one of your voters
you don't deserve one person's vote
because these people have admonished
good people just want to protect Life by
pretending that they don't care about
those babies after they're born every
pro-life person I know cares about that
baby after it's born and would be the
first person if they were asked to help
that child but the good news is it was
Chris Christie and he's a failure anyway
so he's not going to win anything true
that's true I was angry and then you
reminded me of that I feel better now
thank you for bringing me I the only uh
logical end result is a nationwide uh
abortion ban full B that's and that's
not me saying what I want to happen
that's what I'm saying I don't see a
logical pathway towards anything other
than that under the uh argument that
either this country goes the direction
of the removal of human rights based on
numerous factors so this would be like
the rever reverting of the 14th
Amendment or it's extended to all life
so this is one of the big questions of
the Civil War well you know who's the
serving of Human Rights and said okay
some states will ban it and some won't
because we're a nation of a bunch of
states and everyone can choose their own
thing then everyone started shooting
each other beding Kansas was a was
directly a conflict over slavery whether
not the state would be a slave state or
a free state and then ultimately it's
like okay the federal government needs
to answer this question the 14th
Amendment comes in play and says all
humans they get human rights among other
things now they're actually arguing a
human being in the womb does not have
human rights and Ro v Wade was a federal
answer to the question but it needs to
be codified by Congress probably not
Supreme Court so it's probably the right
move for the Supreme Court to say this
is not for us to decide but it's for the
federal government for Congress to say
we make this determination unless we do
a constitutional amendment so I believe
the federal government needs to have a
position on whether or not an unborn
baby gets constitutional rights even the
right to bear arms even as as L as it
sounds the in all all human rights
protected um for the born I believe that
the only logical question is going to be
that yeah I would say Convention of
states and changing the actual
Constitution to add a new amendment is
more likely than our Congress doing
something federally I just don't think
they'll ever agree on it they'll ever
have the numbers and that's the problem
the 14th Amendment says all persons born
or naturalized in the United States and
subject to the jurisdiction therein keep
States state wherein they reside no
State shall make enforce law that shall
Bridge the privilege immunities of
citizens of the United States nor nor
shall any state deprive any person of
life liberty or property without due
process of law any person and now yeah
but you're talking about persons born or
natural in the United States read it
again I just read it read it again nor
Deni to any person with jur equal
protections of the law okay so let's
hold up show me where I'm wrong show me
what I'm missing here right we've
already we we've we've gone over this
like 27 times persons born or natural
all person born or naturalized in the
United States are sub and subject to the
jurisdiction thereof are citizens of the
United States and of the state where
they reside period next Clause no St
shall make or enforce any law that shall
abridge the Privileges or immunities of
citizens of the United States nor shall
any state deprive any person of life
These are separate Clauses yes separate
Clauses totally different statements so
it's no longer about if you're born or
not it's just saying a state has no
right let me let me clarify to do that
non-citizens in this country are
guaranteed due process so when it says
all persons born or naturalized are
citizens that has nothing to do with
whether or not you are granted due
process noncitizens tourists to this
country have free speech and they are
granted due process rights when it comes
to uh violations of the law that would
mean yes unborn babies would not be
citizens but if they are persons they
cannot be uh uh deprived of their life
liberty or property without due process
are they persons absolutely is that just
an assumption or is that a legal
definition I'm saying the Supreme Court
will have to answer that question it is
not a state question to answer the
states states don't have a right to say
that certain people are are not persons
the federal government must do it must
answer its own Amendment Let's uh let's
didn't have time to address and why you
and not former president Trump would be
the party's best choice to tackle these
important issues you each have a minute
Senator Scott we'll start with you one
minute there is a crisis that is growing
in our nation and that crisis is
cultural and spiritual we need a renewal
a Great Awakening we should reject the
left's valueless faithless fatherless
Society we should turn back to Faith
patriotism and individual responsibility
we should stop choosing victimhood and
start choosing Victory we should stop
kneeling in protest and start kneeling
in prayer there are basic truths that
built this country if you're abled
bodied in America you work if you take
out a loan you pay it back if you commit
a violent crime you go to jail and if
God made you a man you play sports
against men I do not just want to
audience please I do not
just I do not just want to win the
battle againsted to get together to he
waited all night for that I
actually values that changed my life
Senator Scott thank you Governor Christy
you haveon for your
vote
thank you for hosting tonight listen
it's a gift A Gift To Be An American and
I'm running for president United States
because I'm tired I'm tired of seeing
the division I'm tired of seeing the
anger lose weight I can
see their exhaustion their exha real of
all of us talking about him have taken
over this country over the last number
of years you're tired for presid
consequence to do the big things to make
sure that America's role in the world
stays number one that we stand up for
our friends and allies around the world
and we stand up for what we believe in
right here at home and it's not to
eliminate our differences our
differences has always been our strength
as a country not our weakness but you
can't truly say you love America
evidence unless you're ready to open up
your heart to every American I'm going
to open up my heart to every American as
president and I will make sure that I
return honesty Integrity to to the Oval
Office we deserve and should accept
nothing less Governor thank you very
much let's go to Mr Ros Swami now one
minute we've talked a lot about Foreign
Wars tonight but we're in the middle of
a war right here at home it's a war not
between black and white or Democrat and
Republican it's between those of us who
believe in our founding ideals and love
this country and a fringe minority who
hates the United States of America and I
think it's going to take a
commander-in-chief to lead us to victory
in that war
who first of all knows that we're in a
war second of all can't be captured by
the special interests along the way but
third is from the Next Generation
somebody with fresh legs to lead us to
Victory I'll shut down the Deep State
I'll declare economic independence from
China I'll keep us out of World War III
and then revive national pride in this
country I also want to close with one
message to the Democrat Party end this
farce that Joe Biden is going to be your
nominee of the United States he's a
puppet for the managerial class so have
the guts to step up and be honest about
who you're actually going to put up we
can have B should step aside end his
candidacy now so we can see whether it's
Nome or Michelle Obama or whoever else
it's but yes I agree very good the v in
my I don't know he took out a lot of a
lot of them
tonight I don't know how it's going to
out like stuff but it really does
a war in the Middle East China on the
March the Flor it is very important that
we know how to defend our freedoms and
how to defeat terrorism and socialism we
have to know the difference between good
and evil we have to know the difference
between right and wrong we need to know
that a strong America doesn't start wars
a strong America prevents Wars and the
way we can focus on that is to make sure
we go back to the soul of America and be
strong and proud again and we can't do
that we can't win the fights of the 21st
century with politicians from the 20th
century we have to move forward and we
can do this I know we can do this so
join our movement go to nikey.com and we
will once again show what America that's
strong and proud looks like God bless
Ambassador thank you no thank you yikes
I'll pass on that one she follows me on
Twitter May
must require leadership I will take the
hits I will take the arrows I will take
the barbs CU it's not about me it's
about you it's not about the past it's
about your future we are going to fight
for you I am going to win for you and
your family and I'm going to lead this
country's Revival as a veteran of the
Iraq War and in the Navy I will always
put service above self as president as
the father of three young kids I'm going
to ensure that this country is Left To
The Next Generation in better shape than
we found it and as the governor of
Florida I delivered on all my promises
and you can trust me to deliver for you
as the President of the United States I
am asking for your vote I'll be a
nominee that will be able to win the
election I will be a leader you can be
proud of and as your president I will
not let you down God bless you Governor
Sanders thank
you
Mr Hol going to take us out that
is that is going to conclude our all
right 95% sa aake W he crushed Ron's got
3% Nikki has got one and Chris has got
one uh I didn't exclude Tim Scott from
the poll to make like a dig at Tim Scott
it's just YouTube only allows four
categories it was pretty clear would it
say he had 1% too if Chris Chris Chris
Christie got one prob got look let me
say uh I like got way more than Chris
Christie way more than Nikki Haley but
he should not be on a presidential
debate stage it was like he was thinking
about what to say next like his words
were being like did you notice that like
what I no definitely and I think he
forgot some stuff you know it was just I
don't think he was fully prepared for
some of those questions he's emotional
uh the like the appeal to emotion to
like he's taking yeah his time with
every word that he says so it means I
think it's the wrong time in history for
that too because people have less and
less attention span like even myself I
know when I'm watching videos or
podcasts or whatever I turn it on to
where it's one and a half times as fast
I'm listening way faster than I ever
have in my life a lot of people are in
the same boat so when you hear somebody
talking really slowly like this it
starts to feel like they don't know what
they want to say oh I've noticed that on
this show as a co-host cuz Tim will talk
really fast and then if I come in like
this everyone's like shut up shut up
it's like no no talk faster get it out
of the way everybody says that about you
Ian like I didn't want to tell tell you
but it's been a big conversation you
know behind your back no I'm just
kidding we're going to read some super
chats so uh we're not going to have a
members on the uncensored show tonight
because it was a debate night and uh you
know they go long so uh we're just going
to read super chats and YouTube's been
doing this weird thing where it's not
loading properly yeah I know what's
going so I didn't refresh so we got uh
the first few super chats here we
started a little early Clint Tores says
howy people hey Clint Clint with the
first Super Chat look at me says I'm the
captain now well maybe maybe number one
look at me all right
and uh here we go Cil luux production
says anyone who raises a foreign
nation's flag at or capital in front of
the White House should be considered
traitors only the American flag should
be uh W should wave there period right
on interesting we're going to we're
going to refresh it and hopefully get
all of the super chats to load now
without um because it cuts off the early
ones when we reload it yo uh VI's debate
performance may be the best debate
performance I have ever seen he pulled a
Bill Clinton like like Clinton his first
debate was lame and then came in and he
must have had great review of his own
performance and came in and just smashed
it in 1992 and now there similar to what
the did I don't know that you'll ever
beat that moment where Trump said
because you'd be in jail so good that's
true that's a tough one to be but I mean
like holistically like from start to
finish let's just say that V had the low
blow Haymakers to Donald Trump's massive
jab right in face KN yeah knock out the
only way you could do totally better is
if you pulled the same thing and you
actually put her in jail you know that
would be in Improvement however hard to
beat that moment I think it's I mean
honestly Jesse uh Kelly was talking or
was tweeting today he said something
about talking about Trump and it's his
opinion that Trump's going to go to jail
and I think that he's probably right I
agree and I don't know if I don't know
if there's normies that are going to
vote for uh you know a president that's
in in jail I think there are oh I don't
think that there I don't think there's
enough to get him over the to get him
over well I mean it'll be it'll be the
Pres it'll be Donald Trump versus
whoever and I would I would personally
prefer to see someone like V in the
spot because he's not in jail than to
see Donald Trump running from jail if
Donald Trump doesn't go to jail then I
think that Donald Trump has a better
shot I think if Donald Trump does go to
jail I think that that just puts normies
off because there's so many nor
they're just not smart enough he went
jail can't vote for him this is not this
is not a this is not my preference I'm
just saying that this is this is what it
seems most likely to me we have and a
correction too it was the stream that we
had of trump had 7,700 Okay cool so uh
delar says Trump had 130k and theate had
70 I wonder how how that I think I think
the issue is are we combining everything
are you talking about like Trump Trump's
core stream because we had Trump
Junior's Channel and it wasn't loading
properly right yeah
all right super dank says D santis is
the heel and V is the baby face this is
a WWE match
correct I mean that's pretty much all of
politics at this point Dave Ruben
tweeted that VI is such an insufferable
prick and he's getting ratioed really
really hard for look man dude I just
Ruben just got baited into giving VI a
lot of PL a lot of uh I think I think
the people who who hitch their wagon to
Ronda santis are probably sweating
bullets you've got to be kind of upset
with these performances and also you
know I mean Dave's a smart guy I think
that he knows deep down the campaign has
not been run the way that it should have
been run if you really wanted to have a
great shot here VI on the other hand has
set himself up well whether it's his
team's doing or his own I don't know but
somebody there has set himself up well
in the event that something does happen
with President Trump you know because I
think a lot of the people who support
Trump are going to shift that direction
should something like that happen unless
it's somebody who comes in late you know
I don't know if they'll be able to get
on the ballot though in that case you
know so there's a lot up in the air but
I do know that the way they've run the
campaign they're not set up well to take
in Trump voters in any event you know
it's just there's a lot of hard feelings
and stuff and I don't think it's going
to turn out well and I think if you're
somebody who hitched yourself really
early on to Ron you're probably upset by
the way have been run and it makes you a
little more testy with situations like
this I think that's another strong point
with v is V has because he's not
attacking Trump everyone kind of feels
like he's the guy that's like he's he's
maybe he's going for VP or whatever um
or whatever you know your your
prediction might want to be but because
of his take on Trump and because he's
been very you know passive towards Trump
he leaves the door open for all the
Trump voters that if they're not going
to vote for Trump and Trump's you know I
talked before about Trump's floor is
very very solid there are dieh hard his
bottom is solid his bottom is solid yes
Rock um but yes but because of that if
Trump isn't in the running it's very
easy for those people to slide over into
V's camp and because of the fact that V
what V is talking about is very similar
to Trump's policies they're not there's
not a lot of daylight between them um
and I think that the is probably more
informed on the policies than Trump is
pretty much the same policies but more
eloquently stated you know so like it's
like it was a hard sell to sell Trump
policies to let's say somebody who went
to an Ivy League or somebody who was in
a tech startup that is you know doing
some Innovative thing vivate can
communicate to those people the exact
same policy that they just scoffed at
and treated like it was crazy coming
from Trump they hear it from him and
they go oh that's really smart and it's
it's not a by product of somehow the
policy gets better it's just that the
communication is clear to that person
but meanwhile VI he's also still
communicating to your typical Trump Bas
voter like like me you know like I voted
for Trump both times I fully understand
in the same way in respect that I did
with Trump and I think that's why he
pulls in some interesting different
people that were pushed away maybe by
Trump in the beginning so it's
interesting but I mean Trump is
obviously still the leader I don't I
don't think he's going to prison in a
way that would prevent him from being
able to become president let me let me
read this from uh Char Deets he says I'm
pro life but I also believe in choice
for others God gives all mankind Free
Will and I think we can have our own
beliefs and values uh what do it say
butt bits up to but but it's I see the B
was a was an accidental type Meant to
hit the space bar to each individual uh
I completely
disagree you cannot have one state being
like it's not murder if you kill a
person from this background it's not
murder that you you can't have that you
can't have one state be like we think
this is not a person it's like are they
a person or not answer the question yeah
I'm looking at natural person it's the
natural person because there are other
persons that are corporations but if are
babies at two months in the womb
considered natural persons legally
that's really what it comes down to
federal government needs have an answer
for that and uh my attitude is yeah I'm
I I'm not traditional pro-life I'm
traditional pro-choice and um while I
think abortion is wrong I think there's
very difficult constitutional questions
in how you balance the rights of two
individual sharing one body and then
ultimately I just want to uh encourage
Democrats to get the abortions they want
to get uh uh you know Democrats and
liberals and leftists you know I will I
will help facilitate uh their their uh
trips and see I don't want them to get
abortions I want their kids to to find a
different pathway than their parents did
I want them to be able to have all the
success and happiness in the world I
thought this was sort of a a good little
nugget from what has been a difficult
debate for a lot of people and there's a
lot of Truth in it Elon Musk said women
in the west have been taught that an
accidental pregnancy is the worst thing
that could possibly happen to them thus
they strongly oppose abortion banss as
being an existential threat many men
also fear that they will be unable to
have fun if abortion is outlawed these
things are all unequivocally true okay
and I responded to him and said the
tragedy is that kids will fulfill most
people more than anything else they do
in life and Elon responded absolutely
and I think that's
something that if I could communicate to
any young person today who has never
been in the room when the ultrasound
happens who has not been there and seen
a child be born into the world who has
not been there and taught their kid how
to ride a bike or any of these things I
would say you know reject this idea
you've been sold that this is some clump
of cells realize this is an extension of
you this is your opportunity to do do
better all those things in your life
that you feel like you haven't done
quite well enough or you feel like you
wish you could be more your child can be
they're a clean slate and that doesn't
mean you project all of your failures
and say oh this person needs to be the
betterman of all my failures but
understand that they can be greatness
and to cancel that out and extinguish it
before they've ever had the
chance I mean you're not only you're not
only imp eting on their ability and
their right to life and their right to
become the greatest thing they can be
Patrick you're hurting yourself Patrick
B David uh tweets Not only was V the
unanimous winner a St uh a star was born
today he shined he was loose he was
comfortable yet intense he even gave
credit to dis sandis and Tim Scott
multiple times a good balance between a
fighter leader and synergist he kept
going to dis sandis on break on each
break and spark a conversation with him
another sign of synergist he kept giving
different perspectives changing
definition of Overdose to ter poisoning
he was so captivating tonight that if
you watch the replay you'd notice even
his opponent's impressed with his
answers yeah he he framed everything
really really well he was he was in
control of the framing of all the
questions when he was answering like
whatever they brought to him he made
sure that it was in a he was answering
in a way that made it understandable for
the average person and also was on his
terms yeah really now asks why y'all
only listening to three- fifths of what
Tim Scott says I'll tell you I'll tell
you he talked at three fifths the speed
no that's that's not it at all it's
because uh I get I I I certainly
understand the joke but uh why were we
muting Tim Scott he wasn't actually
giving answers sorry after like a couple
of the questions where they're like what
would you do about the Border I would
secure the Border because the Border
needs to be secured and then once I
secure the Border I would deal with
immigration in the country I'm like all
right off yeah it's just boil plate if
it's worse than boiler plate it's like
what would you do about the problem of
laws the Border I'd bring the law next
question okay like you didn't answer the
question dude yeah I wanted to hear
people talk talk about flying spy drones
over the Border like constant just drone
surveillence over the Border that's what
we need you said debate with a
trade do that we know that they're
already coming there's no we don't need
to figure out they do that I wanted them
to talk about it they have drones at the
southern border they fly all the time
Non-Stop and at the Canadian border as
well we need to have a debate where
you're on stage and you're just shouting
out what you're thinking yes graphine
hydrogen fuel these are things VI needs
to talk about on the next one no but I
did notice that with that person said in
the Super Chat that the opponents you
know you can notice with the smiles that
was Patrick by David oh it was okay you
notice with the
smiles that you'd see some of the
opponent's smile after he finished with
his answer in like a way that's like you
can't hold it in because you know you're
like damn that was good you know that
happened a couple times like these
people will be in V's cabinet kind of
energy I don't know if that's going
happen with Obama I think they really
liked him on stage when they were
debating 08 and Patrick B David for the
record was there in the room that's
where he's why of course he saw between
commercial breaks what he was seeing do
you think Hillary Clinton ever really
liked Barack Obama I don't think so no I
don't know yeah I don't think so way I
don't think I don't I don't think there
was real fond feelings there I'm so
excited to take these debates to the
next level of science scientific
accuracy and really talk about
technology that is the solution to the
energy sector and the defense sector
like def of defense is heavily invested
in this graphine production out of Rice
University and the hydrogen fuel
production yeah these are things that
that the average that the average person
they're just their eyes are going to
gloss over and they're going be like
yeah you need to let people know they
they people people understand kitchen
table issues if you have like if so V is
very very knowledgeable when it comes to
like science and technology and stuff
like that he's he's owned biotech
company or whatever if he started
talking like that he would lose
everybody you got to go slow you you
have to talk to you have to go to people
where they are and just being like this
is my plan for the future and has all
these things that most people don't even
know what you're talking about and not
yeah like it it's it's it's not it's not
a good way to do it V's approach I think
tonight was really really good like I
said ear he he framed everything in a
way that people can understand and he
was clear and concise that was the most
important thing he he really needed in
his campaign I think before he always
seemed like he was like the the college
boy type person this time I think he was
way more relatable and got people he had
some gotas you know so remember when
Matt Gates was on this show last yeah
when was that that was like a month ago
I guess right about a month stage it was
over a month we had on stage on Friday
episode yeah what it was so this is like
a this is like five weeks now when he
was here I smashed my pinky in between
the chair and the table so that's why my
pinky is discolored and so I'm just like
counting the days since Matt Gates has
been here by the length of my fingernail
have you soaked it in Epsom salt no if
water and epsom salt that'll there's a
hole in it it's dented and blood is
coming out the back he wants you to put
graphine in it I have some right here
actually now you're talk about it have
you ever seen it in person it's like
black powder but like sand he wants you
to stick your finger in there yeah I'm
not sure if that would be good or all
right Alexander scarpi says Viv should
be Trump's Chief of Staff he needs to be
continuously in Trump's ear yeah dude
that would be killer actually if Trump
is President that'd be killer and if
anything I kind of feel like
VI everything he's saying as he it's
like you got these older neocons we talk
about bs garbage no one cares about
except for maybe older neocons and then
de is basically saying remember me in
2028 yeah and maybe Trump sends him to
the UN you know where Nikki went last
time and this time just burn it down I
don't know I don't know maybe I mean
look dude's a billion almost he's half a
Billionaire's he's what what his net
worth 650 650 million or something like
that I think yeah I don't think a guy
like that wants to just be an ambassador
no VP or president if if if there was a
stage where I think there's a job out
there I don't know I don't know which
one it be maybe it's Governor or senate
or something like that because he's in
Ohio isn't he yeah yeah so I could see
him trying in the next Ohio governor
election I don't know when that is
because I think dwine was just elected
again in
2022 um i' have to double check that
2020 maybe or 2022 um so maybe that's
maybe that's the future you know uh 2019
2019 was yeah uh no no wait American
attorney since yeah 2019 he was elect as
a 70th governor of Ohio yeah so maybe
that's the the future move because I
could see him doing a great job in that
position as a governor and kind of
proving the model of his leadership on
on a state level and then you know I've
got a feeling that he would become like
a personality on talk show personality
instead I see that too only because he
said he doesn't want anything than the
best he's not interested in anything
other than but Governor's a pretty cool
Ro before he ran he was preparing to
roll out a podcast wasn't he he does
have a podcast he does have one okay
yeah it's actually very good I remember
seeing it it's on
YouTube I mean dude he had the opening
and the closing it was
amazing I don't think there was an
answer he gave that was bad you know no
I didn't like that he interrupted Nikki
I didn't like that he was interrupting
he didn't have to do that you get
powerful enough you don't have to
interrupt anymore at least you think the
right thing I didn't mind it it works
when Donald Trump does it
I think sometimes
like if you wait too long it starts to
feel like oh they had to sit there and
think out this response in a debate
format I don't have a problem with it if
you're in a room having a respectful
conversation with somebody yes wait for
them to finish what they have to say
respond in a debate live on TV where
people want to see your leadership and
quick thinking ability I see no problem
cutting in and saying hey no I'm going
to correct this on the spot you know
yeah
all right well I mean we don't actually
don't have that many super chats so yeah
kind of surprised yeah people are so
invested in the show it's mostly just uh
v v and fire emojis and stuff like that
R Swami yeah so I think look this is a
special uh debate night show we usually
don't do members only shows because we
go into Super chats afterwards but uh I
don't know I guess I guess it's uh the
debate's over I feel like we uh you know
I got to say it I don't care for the
Lesser known GOP debates I insult them
routinely I didn't want to do this one I
was even talking to Luke yesterday I'm
like I don't care about the debate dude
like let's talk about the news it's like
this the manifesto stuff but I'm glad we
did watch it because V was was was epic
and uh that that was pretty awesome but
I I guess that being said uh we'll just
wind things up so uh smash the like
button subscribe to the channel most
importantly watch infringed we're not
going to have the members only
uncensored because as I mentioned
usually when there's like a speech a
presidential State of the Union or
something thing we just run through the
show and then it it goes long or
whatever but uh if you're looking for
something to do watch infringed I really
you got to watch it's an hour and 40
minutes maybe it's too late for you to
check it out but uh seriously share it
with your friends we're going to be
doing way more this is a a an expensive
project for us it the the budget is is I
don't know quar million bucks probably
is is what we're aiming towards right
now what we're looking at in terms of
production and marketing and we're
probably going to be going higher than
that depending on uh what we can with it
I think running the commercials for it
itself is helping win the culture war
and defend gun rights so you know you
can watch that at Tim cast.com on the
front page you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast Robbie do you want to shout
anything out you can follow me at Robbie
Starbuck or sub to me on any of those
channels see Clips coming out from our
documentary later this
year I am uh fil that remains on X or
Twix I am Phil that remains official on
Instagram the band is All That Remains
you can follow us on Spotify Apple music
uh Pandora YouTube you know the internet
and I just got confirmation from lucer
Kowski uh we are Chang she's gonna have
VI ramaswami on the show tomorrow 3M 3
p.m. subscribe to we are change on
YouTube and keep an eye open for that
and confirm the the heels of uh he
posted a picture excellent and then also
subscribe on Rumble rumble.com wear
change because they usually take the
second half of the show over there and
get down and dirty so you'll hear the
real stuff there I'm Ian crossin and go
check out we were talking a lot about
energy tonight was a big part of the
theme of saving the world check out my
YouTube channel I interviewed yzel
moscowitz who's talking about reusing
95% of our spent nuclear fuel to create
closed systems so that we don't have to
worry about mining it from Kazakhstan or
uh Canada we can actually just reuse
what we got and continue our nuclear
Productions capacity and also uh that's
episode number four episode number two
was James Tu talking about uh
retrofitting our economy into a
hydrogen-based fuel system and
mass-producing graphine with which we
can build the wall and many walls and
many ships for our Navy uh very exciting
subscribe to me on YouTube and I'll see
you later I am surge.com I agree let's
build that Northern wall against the
maple curtain we need to get something
up there cuz uh these Canadians are just
you know going to keep pouring over the
border so uh I again I'm surge.com yeah
let's deal with this frostback problem
and just I'm just kidding I really am
just kidding I have a lot of good
Canadian friends uh we just had some
Canadians on the other when you get off
today they're going to go hey yeah I
hope they
apologize they're going to say I'm sorry
I bothered you
by all right everybody uh thanks for
hanging out we'll be back tomorrow we'll
see y all
then